so the Ontario government has frozen the
funding from give send go first GoFundMe
says we're shutting this down now you've
got government officials basically
saying that these donations are are you
you can't give them out it's illegal
it's a legal activity they're going to
block it from transferring through banks
it's pretty serious but let me just say
over Target much when black lives matter
goes out and does whatever they want
when antifa goes out and does whatever
they want they don't care they barely do
anything why because it's not actually
in opposition to the system and that's
how you can tell when truckers show up
and park their cars it is so disruptive
Trudeau has crybaby panic attacks and
the government desperately tries to stop
the funding of these protests we got
more news that apparently I don't know
if this is true there's going to be a
U.S Convoy starting at the Super Bowl
and I kind of I don't know if I believe
that because that sounds like you know
why would truckers go and protest
regular people who are minding their own
business why would they go to a
government building or DC or something
but we'll get into all that stuff we've
also got inflation
inflation is bad it's the worst since
1982 except when you actually take a
look at how the Consumer Price Index is
calculated if we were to calculate the
today's inflation rate using the same
methodology as 1982 it's actually worse
and you have to go back to World War II
to see worse inflation that is to say
Joe Biden is presiding over some of the
worst inflation we've seen in 70 years
okay fine we'll use the modern
calculation and say 40 years but the
thing is every single month they say the
same thing why because every single
month inflation just keeps getting worse
all right
we'll talk about that we also had at
Madison Square Garden in New York City a
sold out crowd at Madison Square Garden
chanting let's go Brandon which is
insane because it's New York City you
know I think people hate Biden but uh
well wondering all that stuff uh joining
us to talk about all this is Nick Cersei
how's it going man thanks for coming
thanks for having me it's great to be
here it's a good cool setup appreciate
it man uh do you want to introduce
yourself well um I think everybody knows
who I am I'm people in the chat
certainly oh yeah yeah yeah I'm Nick
Cersei hey everybody there you go yeah
International film and television star
people may know you from such shows as
justified in movies like Fried Green
Tomatoes Castaway yeah Castle oh you're
in that movie Tom Cruise yeah not the
volleyball not the volleyball Tom Hanks
although the volleyball got more
close-ups yeah right on and you also uh
you only ask you the film capital
punishment yeah a documentary that we
made about uh what's happening to the
people who went to Washington on January
6th right on well we can talk about all
that as well as the Gosnell film you
made that that's about uh the wow we got
to be careful how we describe this
because it's so graphic and gruesome
most prolific serial killer in American
history yes killing babies yes and and
I'm and we're not being you know
facetious acute or hyperbolic about
abortion no he literally killed babies
right he would induce birth and then
kill the baby yikes so well maybe we'll
say that for the members members portion
because that's that's that's real dark
stuff that's pretty extreme pretty dark
for sure but we got Sheamus here as well
Sheamus Coughlin uh not everyone knows
who I am I run a YouTube channel called
Freedom Tunes we upload a new cartoon
every Thursday we just uploaded one
today called fed talks and it's a parody
of TED Talks I think you guys will
really enjoy it it's uh very relevant to
what's been going on in the news with
some of these undercover operations I
hope you all check that out and enjoy it
you can cross on here I'd like to maybe
thinking maybe we could change the way
we think about inflation say inflation's
getting better which means the economy
is getting worse yeah yeah
so you guys check me out Ian crosson.net
but I'll be seeing you soon I'm really
excited for tonight's talk Nick is a
very accomplished actor and I'm sure his
lot to say about the
wonderful world of Hollywood and
hopefully we can get into God's not
really interested in that and actually
worked with the armorer that Alec
Baldwin had worked with too so we'll get
into that stuff but before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com and sign up right up on the
top right side you can become a member
as a member you're helping employ our
journalists you're helping us do this
show you're making sure we can keep the
lights on of course there's always
creepy weirdos are trying to come after
us and get us canceled and shut down and
that's why we rely so heavily on our
memberships to make sure this business
continues to operate as a member you'll
get access to exclusive members only
segments from this show this special
segment will be up around 11 or so p.m
so make sure you sign up and check it
out we could really use your support and
don't forget to smash that like button
one like is one hunk and I'll also add
for some reason YouTube won't allow me
to post that anymore it's crazy for a
while I was posting one like equals one
hunk
and then I would pin it to the chat and
for the past few days it won't let me
every time I try it just arrows out and
doesn't post the message but isn't it
hilarious how desperate they are there's
literally nothing The Establishment can
do to stop these people and they're like
well we won't let you say honk on the
Internet that happened apparently it's
like okay from Facebook for posting hunk
yeah well we'll we'll get into that so
uh subscribe share the show with your
friends and let's get started with this
this is huge news this is I can't
believe it from globalnews.ca Ontario
freezes funds from give send go trucker
Convoy fundraiser the Ontario government
says it has successfully petitioned a
court to freeze access to millions of
dollars donate through online online
fundraising platform give sign to go my
first question is are they based in
Canada and how can you actually stop
this from getting to people you can't
the give send go uh organizers could
just convert it to bitcoin or crypto and
there's nothing anyone can do to stop
them however that would be against this
court order just so you know I don't
know if it's illegal but they're going
to say the province obtained an order
from the superior court of just this
that prohibits anyone from Distributing
donations made through the website's
Freedom Convoy 2022 and adopt a trucker
campaign Pages said a spokesman for
Premier Doug Ford Ivana Yelich said the
order binding any and all parties with
possession or control of these donations
was issued Thursday afternoon she cited
a section of the criminal code that
allows the Attorney General to apply for
a restraint order against any offense
related property this is really really
amazing stuff I want to show you this uh
this this post from Andrew Lawton here's
a quote says the Ontario government says
it has effectively Frozen all donations
quote today the Attorney General brought
brought an application in the superior
court of justice for an order pursuant
to section 490.8 of the criminal code
prohibiting any person from disposing of
or otherwise dealing with in any manner
whatsoever any and all monetary
donations made through the freedom
Convoy 2022 and adopted trucker campaign
pages on the give send go online
fundraising platform this afternoon the
order was issued it binds Annie and all
parties with possession or control over
these donations
I don't know are the people who have set
the page Canadian and I wonder
ultimately if it's if it's gonna matter
yeah well also even if they're not based
in Canada the Canadian government can
say we'll never let you operate within
the borders of our country again or
something along those lines unless you
surrender the money to US well so here's
what I don't understand right they say
disposing of disposing of so so if you
have these donations and you're like I'm
gonna refund them you're you can't do
that you can't refund them it says
otherwise dealing with what if what if
they came out and said you know well
look if we can't give them to truckers
we're going to give it back to people no
you can't do that either so they're
effectively stealing the money yes
locking it in place that no one can
touch it that's what it sounds like
sounds like despotism yeah well but look
at how these kinds of things go when BLM
riots burns down cities gets people
killed absolutely destroys lower class
neighborhoods they are given Federal
relief money from JB pritzker uh in
Illinois your taxes end up funding them
when people voluntarily decide that they
want to support working-class people
standing up for their rights as workers
that money is stolen from them looks
like uh Gibson goes based out of Boston
Massachusetts according to
crunchbase.com so I would imagine they
don't really have any any liability here
they can do no no foreign government can
make them do anything uh but it's the
people who started the page interesting
so that's what they're in Canada yeah
yeah I just don't I don't understand how
they can do that I don't I don't see how
that works I mean how do they stop them
from from giving money to somebody that
they want to give money to I mean what
and and who that's right so so that's
why this is It's
you know let me just slow down
holy they are desperate yes they're
they're saying this money from this fund
you can't do anything with why because
how do they prove the money was given to
someone involved in the trucker Convoy
if they if there's a guy named Bob Smith
and they're like we gave him five
hundred thousand dollars you know
they're going to be like well that's the
Convoy no it doesn't prove it prove this
guy how yeah and so they just say well
then no one can touch any of the money
well so what happens then if I mean this
is ultimately I think they're trying to
cause damage to give send go right
well it's a Gibson go was a you know
it's a Christian organization that was
created as a response to GoFundMe being
so relentlessly left-wing and and fun
you know the Gosnell movie they started
the the fundraising campaign to raise
money for the gosnellon GoFundMe and
then GoFundMe rejected it you know said
they couldn't raise money on that
platform because of the subject matter
and so they had to go to Indiegogo wow
it's it's they've been they've been this
way for years well the thing with Gibson
go I mean was my comment earlier off
base is it possible that the Canadian
government could legitimately just say
to them you can't operate here unless
you surrender them the funds to the
company itself yeah yeah like what other
mechanism yeah what other mechanism is
there yeah is what I'm curious about but
you're saying it's a Christian company
so I hope that's not the case and I hope
they would stick up for their principles
yo I don't want to suggest that is
what's happening I have no clue I hope
Canada bans give Zen to go and I don't
mean that literally I mean that like try
it yeah imagine what that would sound
like to the rest of the world Canada
bans fundraising platform form for
engaging in offenses
wow there this is I just got to say over
Target yeah kind of kind of scary
actually how effective the trucker thing
is and how panicked they are they're
trying to claim oh far right right wing
all that other garbage and it's just a
bunch of trucks that parked you know
what I mean they're gonna keep claiming
it if you guys do you guys hear that
they want to go after their kids now
yeah yeah there was that story where
apparently they are child endangerment
or something if you bring your kids with
you to the concert it didn't work no
so now they're just like give us your
money but it's not gonna work it's not
gonna work you know you know what's
crazy is it's really easy to throw a
wrench in the spokes it's really it's
really hard to build an engine it's
really easy to break one yep so you get
these guys who got these big rigs it's
not the most expensive operation ever
planned it's not the most expensive
expensive protest we've ever seen it's
just one of the most effective imagine
imagine if there really is going to be a
you know this like a U.S trucker Convoy
or whatever if trucker is just even in
small groups decided we're going to take
what we want from now on they could no
one could stop them yeah to me it looks
like they really need something that's
less centralized so they tried um
GoFundMe and now they're trying give
send go and they're having kind of the
same problems with both platforms even
though Gibson go is much Freer than
GoFundMe was it sounds like they need a
way to get these individual funds to the
truckers that need it uh without going
through a central system and it's crazy
no you're not if you're using Fiat in
any way it's going to go through a
central service to get to its Target
right the only way to do something
non-centralized here I think if the
present would be with crypto from your
wallet that's what it sounds like so we
actually have a statement from give send
to go they tweeted know this Canada has
absolutely zero jurisdiction over how we
manage our funds here at Gibson go all
funds for every campaign on give send go
flow directly to the recipients of those
campaigns not least of which is the
freedom Convoy campaign beautiful yeah
except good for them if the people who
are getting the money are in Canada then
the Canadian government's going to go
after their bank accounts so Gibson go
can be like yo you can't do anything
with money yeah well yeah the money's
flowing but they're going after the
individuals who are raising the money so
I'm wondering if the people who set it
up are in Canada and that's that's the
big question it would be really funny I
got to be honest if the people who set
the page up are not in Canada and we're
just like Americans who are like we're
gonna we're gonna help fundraise for
this because then Canada really is just
having a temper tantrum and they can do
nothing about it do nothing
well I'm worried about remember how they
just seized the crypto keys from the
people who are running this kind of
Bitcoin scam and I think was New York
City the crocodile of Wall Street or
whatever this lady and her husband call
themselves um so I'm curious if they're
going to try to use this as a way to get
the whole control of crypto jump started
I wonder if they'll use this as a way to
like crypto I just thought last night
first time I thought this I think maybe
crypto itself
Nakamoto Satoshi Nakamoto maybe that
that is like a government operation to
get and then they're gonna crash the
Fiat system and then get everyone on
crypto and then track everybody I mean I
literally said this two years ago it's
finally sinking in today
yeah I mean you so there's that big
story about the crocodile of Wall Street
lady right these two people apparently
they're accused of um wire fraud
stealing hacking you know billions of
dollars in Bitcoin and uh I've been
saying this I remember I was hanging out
with Luke uh from we are change a few
years ago and I was telling all his
buddies and I was like The Ledger is
public every crypto transaction is
public so unless you're using Z cash or
Monero or something but even then these
people who who were got who got busted
they uh were using Monero the government
still tracked it it's like you look man
you got powerful interests that are
terrified you're gonna try and
circumvent the tax base the tax system
they're going to figure out a way to to
find out how much money you got and why
so you know ultimately
this this all comes together when you
realize what a um a lot of people on the
right have been talking about what what
cashless society looks like yes yo
you're in it yeah you're there you know
right now I've got you know I got some
cash in my pocket or whatever if I want
to go buy something no one can take that
cash cash from meals they come and take
it but if you got all your all your
money in a bank account they could just
be like wrong thinker now you can't buy
food right
yeah the other thing we're seeing too
it's kind of like um
as an aside but somewhat related you see
they're having National Guard act as
substitute teachers yeah
National Guard is being deployed to act
as teachers where this in New Mexico uh
79 National Guard were deployed to be
teachers and they're saying there's
going to be more and I'm just like yo
we're getting to the point where they're
going to steal your money right from
underneath you imagine what the future
looks like when they can take your money
away because digital and they control
the banks and the financial institutions
think about the future likes when they
issue a universal basic income everybody
gets 2 000 a month the private sector
has been destroyed by all these insane
restrictions all that's left are big box
stores where you can buy stuff you get a
fun amount of cash the people working at
those stores are all National Guard
sounds a whole lot like communism yes I
heard that they're uh this was just a
one person on Twitter said that by 2026
they want to have kill switches in all
cars like remote switches yeah so that
if you don't are your wrong thinker your
car turns off I don't know yeah I don't
know if it's because if you're a wrong
thinker or something I think it's like a
tech backup or something they don't want
anything to go wrong supposedly they
want it so that when you're running from
Cops exactly yeah
did they just do that didn't they just
hack some guy's GPS system and freeze
his car because he was running from cops
I saw a new story about this I swear you
guys it's for your own good yeah
you're really sounding ungrateful here I
know
yeah just just accept when the
government decides they know what's best
for you exactly because um I think if
history has taught us anything it's that
um
you know the government is always
looking out for your best interests and
the police are great I love that Meme
where it's like so we so it's it's a
Twitter post and the guy's like so yeah
the CIA did bad stuff in the 50s the 60s
the 70s the 80s the 90s the 2000s no
one's ever been criminally charged or
held accountable but we can't assume
they're doing anything wrong now exactly
that's a conspiracy theory yeah I'm
talking to people about how the
government's lying about January 6. I go
oh no they're not I go what what
convince you that the government wasn't
going to lie to you but Vietnam was it
Tuskegee was it yeah JFK what was it but
this is the thing you know when I hear
these people arguing with you about it
just why why even talk to them anymore
it's just I'm I'm so over I'm so beyond
it there there's P the people in the um
I don't know what you call it Liberty
side of things have this tendency to
think that they're playing a fair game
of chess right while the other side is
snickering amongst themselves about how
they've been cheating the whole time
yeah Massey was saying last night Thomas
Massey was on the show congressman and
he was saying that it's like he goes in
there he has to almost forget most of
what he knows about engineering just to
participate in Congress because it's so
emotionally charged and people are like
wild animals you know working off their
feelings yes he didn't say that that's
me interpreting what he said but I I
agree with the emotion thing but it's
it's like it's so much more raw than you
realize
you you're talking to a brick wall you
know when when you're talking to someone
so I'll give you guys an example and
I'll give a shout out to our good
friends The Young Turks because they
deserve it huh we love them I just wanna
I just want to say too you know Anna
kasparian I don't understand why she's
such a mean person she's better than me
I'm totally well I mean she's she's just
a mean person and uh you know I've
talked about The Young Turks I've talked
about a bunch of people and I'll
criticize them but I always try to keep
it to a certain degree depending on who
it is like CNN they get nothing from me
like they're awful you know all of them
I just vile people uh but um you know I
recently tweeted something nice to Jake
euger because he tweeted out try being
nice to someone and see see how it makes
you feel and I was like I I respect and
agree with that so I tweeted at Jack I
was like I think you're a smart man
who's widely successful with one of the
biggest political shows and I respect
your hard work that you put into this
it's all true it's all true the dude has
is wildly successful you don't gotta
like the guy or agree with them to
recognize the thing he's built and he
liked it he clicked the like button on
that so they did this segment we were
talking about January 6th and we had
Enrique tario on of The Proud boys and
uh I had mentioned look the people at
the front gate of the of the the tunnel
entrance of the Capitol and the front
entrance where they're fighting with
cops that whole area all those people
okay that was violence that was a
violent Riot yeah you get arrested for
that you committed act of violence we
arrest you those people yeah hands down
we get it you're gonna get them for
whatever you get them for but there were
a lot of people who are the magamemas as
we call who are walking around and then
all of a sudden you see this video of
the cops opening the barricades and
Fanning people in so my specific point
was
if you're walking down the street and a
police officer goes like this and waves
you in opens up the barricades you are
not trespassing you are not legally
trespassing in any circumstance no now
the prosecutors here might lie and just
claim we don't care what the reality is
that's called tyranny but if let's say
it's not the capital let's say my house
has a barricade up and you're walking on
the street and I open the barricade and
wave you in I cannot then attack you and
claim you trespassed what if there's so
so hold on let me finish this point so
when I tell this story and I said that
the people who entered under the
circumstances I don't see how you can
even get them for trespassing what ends
up happening is you know Anna kasparian
makes this whole video or the one thing
I just don't understand is she's like I
she accuses me of saying these things
knowing it's false because I just want
to make money they then try to allege
that because other people on the other
side of the building were fighting with
cops that means the other people on the
other side of the building who are LED
in by the cops are committing crimes
yeah and I'm just like that's that's the
point of you know I don't bring them up
to actually engage in any meaningful
dialogue with them because they don't
want to no because I've politely asked
them because I have genk on DM I message
him and I'm like hey we'd love to talk
like let's talk they won't do it they
have no interest whatsoever in having
real conversations I'm not going to
insult them I will I will I literally
just complimented the man's work but
instead what they do is they make they
make insults they insult my appearance
they don't engage with the core of what
the actual statement or argument is so
at this point with all of this stuff
going on I just say the only thing that
matters right now that these people are
interested in is power they don't care
about truth they don't care about
arguments it's power and if you if we if
we as the libertarian side of things I
don't mean Big L I mean just the more
freedom-oriented people keep saying why
won't they understand maybe if we keep
trying to convince them to understand
they do understand they're lying about
it look I sent I tweeted Anna I
commented on their video I dm with
periodically saying let's talk and I
said what I said was a specific
reference to a story from ABC ABC News
where the defendants in the case on
January 6 said the police let us in and
told us it was okay and and my point is
if that is discernably discernably true
you can't prosecute on trespassing in
most in any circumstance I mean there's
probably some technicalities instead of
actually taking the core of that
argument she just says Tim's lying for
money he's a grifter he knows he's lying
and they totally misrepresent the
entirety of the conversation there's no
point in arguing with these people so
right now at a point where this country
is so far divided
there's there's just you are wasting
your time when you should be doing
Grassroots organizing some kind of
effective growth strategy there's an old
saying that when you argue with a fool
there are two I do think there's one
exception here
if someone says something ridiculous
like this to you and then you respond
and you have a reasonable argument
the moderates will see that and they
will be more likely to take your side
the future if the person you're arguing
with responds to your reasonable
response in bad faith then I think you
just have to discontinue the
conversation yeah and then they look
like a fool because if you respond to
their bad faith then you look like an
idiot because you look like you're
because honestly you look like you're
reacting emotionally because you know
you can't reason with this person you're
only continuing with the argument
because you want your ego to come out on
top you're not going to win right it's
like playing chess with a pigeon they're
going to knock the pieces off what is
word take a crap and start around like
they're winning is it like I was right
or you were right because we're both
probably right that's right no no dude
dude dude in this specific context there
is a video you can watch of the police
opening the barricades and Fanning
people oh my question is if if there's a
cop on your driveway and you had a no
trespassing sign and they were waving
people in again and you didn't know
would those people not be trespassing
that because a cop waved well but but
yeah if it's if it was a police officer
charger if it was a security agent
specifically charged with protecting the
parameter like the Capitol Police are
specifically charged charge to protect
that parameter and they were the ones
letting people and they were the ones
holding the barricade so let me let me
make this point okay they opened the
barricades up there's video of it
there's numerous videos and multiple
officers Fanning people in now the
argument is they were Fanning the
officers back saying Retreat because the
mob was pushing too hard the mob didn't
break the barriers down the cops opened
them up and that was at least at one
entrance you have to understand that
when it comes to criminal law an
individual is an individual on January
17 2020 the the the police in DC tried
charging anti-fot with as a group under
conspiracy it doesn't work you can't do
it under our legal system that means
each individual in that crowd gets an
individual charge now there's some
circumstances where you get racketeering
you get people as a group right there's
numerous videos of that there's a
there's another video where the doors
are actually opened by the police and
one guy goes I don't know man they're
gonna trap us inside because the police
opened the door and then one Officer
says I don't agree with it but I respect
it
you're walking into a building and a cop
says that how could could you be
criminally prosecuted under trespassing
when trespassing requires you know you
trespassed and I'll give you the
specific example is when we had the
police here
talking to them the officer told us if
you don't have a sign if it's just a
driveway the public is allowed to enter
you can then tell them to leave and they
have to and if they don't then it's
trespassing by placing the sign now it's
trespassing and it is true at the
Capitol there were many signs except not
everywhere and many of them were taken
down and the police even removed some of
those barricades so in your in the home
situation you have to have a sign on the
driveway because what if they walk onto
your property we're not going to get
into this is my question that guarantees
they see it as if it's on the in the
entrance but if they enter from a
different area and they don't see a sign
is it still trespassing even though
there's a sign yes so you're supposed to
assume they're supposed to enter from
the driveway it's a pointless I'm sorry
or on the front door or something if
you're if you're sneaking through the
woods to get on a property or
trespassing there's no argument well if
someone if someone some people walk I
know it's not common but I'm just
wondering for technicality so uh you
would have to trespass on someone else's
property to trespass on a property
without going through normal means that
there's no argument but you were going
to say something new well I was there
myself on January 6 and I saw myself I
saw the police remove the barricades and
let people get up on the steps of the
Capitol I saw saw them do that and when
the people that I saw got on the steps
of the Capitol it wasn't it wasn't
violent it wasn't a riot it was they
were waving flags and they were singing
we're not going to take it and it looked
like a party
I didn't see any of the violence when I
was there but one of the people in our
movie two of the people in our movie are
these two twin 74 year old grandmothers
who went to the Capitol that day and
they said they saw some people going in
and out of the doorway at the Capitol
building and they once said to the other
do you want to go in and they decided to
go in and they talked to the police they
went and they said to the policeman is
it okay if we're in here he said yeah
it's fine they walked in they took some
pictures they walked back out they went
home and three weeks later the FBI is
banging on their door so threatening
them with domestic terrorism you can't
you're on a no-fly list so this is what
you need to understand Ian when you told
Sheamus you know sometimes we're both
right in different ways or whatever you
said that this is not true in this case
The Young Turks either are ignoring what
I actually said on the show when I
explained there's a video showing police
letting people in and saying they were
they respect what they're doing
they ignore that they put the clip of me
saying that in their video and then
argued people were climbing over broken
glass and fighting with cops to get in
so that is taking it either look maybe
maybe they're just not uh smart enough
both are true right there were people
climbing over violence no no no the
video they showed was of me saying the
door was opened by police and the police
said I respect it they then took that of
me saying it and and twisted it so that
Their audience believes I'm saying
people climbed over broken glass how
could that be trespassing which I never
said that you read the comments and it's
so sad and this is why I understand the
desire to want to argue with these
people because they're all saying the
same thing if they were fighting with
cops and breaking glass and climbing
through Windows to get in how how could
Tim be so dumb and I'm like man I sure
do wish The Young Turks were just honest
about what I actually said to her
mkitario that the people who engage in
violence should be prosecuted they
should be in prison the people beating
cops should be arrested the people
fighting with police in the tunnel
should be arrested and the memos who
were welcomed in by police whether you
agree with or not I did not say they're
innocent I said there's you probably
can't prosecute on trespassing unless
there was an explicit warning which
there wasn't there was welcoming
now if they were honest I would I would
I would love to engage in an argument
with them but they're they're taking
what I said out of context changing the
context lying to their audience and then
when I politely say to them I'd love to
explain they refuse to engage look I'll
say it I'm not gonna I'm not gonna mock
Anna the way she does of me and my
appearance and things like that I'll
just say I believe The Young Turks are
legitimately evil people oh I don't know
bro hands down they used to be okay when
I think The Young Turks I think 2006
seven thank God for The Young Turks
because they spoke out against the war
in Iraq and Afghanistan and they were
clear and concise and we needed that but
I think at some point that it that that
company may have been turned inward or
like their rage was like kind of twisted
around and refocused
she could Tweet back at me I didn't
realize you were referring to a news
story from ABC where they legitimately
brought up the defense in court that
police were welcoming them in the
building she ignores it and it's not the
first time Anna conspirinus does this
does this every single instance in which
he referenced me and I offer up a polite
response she ignores it so either she's
purposefully ignoring a legitimate
rebuttal to her wrong statements which
would make her evil or she's she doesn't
realize I'm saying these things but
regardless every step of the way when
The Young Turks have the opportunity to
assess the evidence respond because I've
dm'd Jack yugar numerous numerous
occasions I I've known the guy for a
long time he won the last time I saw him
uh he screamed at me and I saw him at
VidCon he walked up to me this is years
ago shakes man how's it going man how
things have been I've been on a show
several times something something
happened in this country where people
like you say yeah maybe in 2006 Jank
euger was a good dude Maybe
I saw him at VidCon in maybe 2016 I
think it was I can't remember and he
walks up to me and he checks me he's
like how you been man how things going
what's what's going on with YouTube how
are things working for you and then I
see him at politicon a couple years
later and he screams in my face for no
reason you might even have a bad day he
was just he was in the hallway talking
to people I was like Hey Jake how's it
going man I want to talk to you about a
video you did and they start screaming
at me saying all this crazy hungry yeah
but but look I don't want anything my
point is when you get to the point
where I got no beef I have no issue with
them I recognize a disagreement and they
refuse to assess the evidence and then
continue to mislead Their audience I
think it is so important
you've got a news organization you got
like an entertainment magazine and
you're going to be one or you're going
to be there to kind of be in the middle
it's a very dangerous location so like
see this is a characteristic of the lift
that I think has happened over the last
few years and it's that they can't
really even look at your argument they
can't bring themselves to even consider
it so they just try to ignore it they
pretend it's something else they don't
want to look at what you're actually
saying because that would be hard I
think it would hard for them and so they
they tend to just ignore anything
cognitive dissonance yeah it's like we
can't have that cognitive dissonance so
we're just not going to see what you're
talking about We're Not Gonna We're not
gonna look at it or even do a Google
search my favorite and just while we're
on the subject is we did a segment on
the show a year and a half ago or so
where we talked about us there were five
different studies that said
conservatives tend to be more attractive
active than liberals
the point I specifically brought up was
that there is attractiveness privilege
an idea uh prevalent among the left that
people who are more attractive tend to
be more privileged and those who are
privileged are more likely to be
conservative or independent instead of
addressing the context they just made a
video saying Tim pool's ugly and stupid
so so this is the issue I take I'm
willing to 100 assess the situation of
January 6 and say anybody who is violent
and fighting and attacking cops you get
charged for that the people who knocked
over barricades or did anything like
that or grabbed Shields or hit people
tried shoving their way in the tunnel
you commit a crime when you do that you
write you go to you go to jail for that
depending on the severity prison
and then there were other circumstances
in which Alex Jones said don't go in the
building and told people not to go in
and the January 6 committee subpoenas
him and tries going after all his
records which is an insane abuse of
power on the Press then you have regular
people like you mentioned these old
ladies who are told by the police they
are allowed inside the building and now
the media is trying to make it seem like
every single person was a rider who
smashed the window and climbed through
window yo 74 year old lady to climb
through a window bro why is it that The
Young Turks and other people like them
will not even Google search this why is
that when I do a video they watch enough
to clip the video out of context to know
where to cut the context to make sure
their audience doesn't see what I'm
actually talking about but then they
don't investigate further because it's
an intentional action yeah I think it
might be because they want they don't
want Trump to get reelected like when I
I didn't want yeah I didn't want to talk
about my fear that the noise could be
construed as violence like noise
Weaponry because I really support the
truckers so I didn't say anything about
it the first night kind of like I chose
to ignore what I knew was real because I
didn't want to hurt the people I wanted
to win but then I was like I can't live
like that I got to be honest it is a
type of weapon you can you can harm
someone with noise and
you know that's I think that sometimes
you just got to concede like reality I I
but you know I mean there are a lot of
things that you could harm someone with
that doesn't necessarily mean it's being
used in a harmful way
that's true
but to your point uh Jonathan height did
research which unsurprisingly showed
that conservatives are far more likely
to understand left-wing positions than
left Wingers are to understand
conservative positions in anyone who's
conservative who has consumed left-wing
media understood this without his
research and left Wingers who consume
conservative media uh don't exist which
is why we have this problem yeah well
when I talk to people left Wingers
people on the left about my movie most
of them won't watch it they don't no I
don't want to see that that was an
Insurrection those people should all go
to jail they don't want they won't they
can't bear to look at it I even had to
fire my own agent just over the
Christmas holidays because I'm I was
talking to them about you know
about the movie and with the premieres
and you know stuff and he's like hey I'm
not going to watch that I go
dude you're my agent you're not going to
watch my work
because you you're afraid of what it's
just a movie Michael Moore makes them
for your side all the time you can't
even look at it and he said no I just I
just don't want to you know that was a
that was a riot full stop and I go well
I guess then you don't want to be my
agent anymore
or be a text yeah that was over the
phone weird yeah well so I think what
happens in their minds and again maybe
I'm over pathologizing here but I think
this is probably a reasonable assessment
of the potential motivation here a
person might think okay there could be
information here that will change my
mind but I don't want to be the person
who knows that January 6th wasn't an
Insurrection because there is a very
high social cost to pay for having that
awareness you bet you bet
especially in Hollywood absolutely I
went back to my parents house for
Christmas and they're like well what do
you think about that Insurrection at the
capital I was like what do you mean like
when they when they stood inside the old
building and just stood in the hallways
and I was like the government can
operate from anywhere digitally it's not
a real Insurrection would be cutting off
the electricity to the to the continent
like if you want to talk about
Insurrection and they were like huh he's
right
well the other thing too about that day
it's like the the media only showed you
the violence they only showed you the
little pieces the clips right at the
capitol of the windows being broken and
Ashley Babbitt being killed and all that
that's all they showed you there were
two million people there that day there
were so many people and they never
showed you two million yes that we have
estimates of two million people wow
there's a shot in my movie that I had
never seen before we found it of just
the size of the crowd and it's
breathtaking I mean it's amazing they
conflate the rally which occurred
um some some ways away from the capitol
with the Insurrection so for a lot of
people like maybe like your parents Ian
who don't actually investigate or know
what's going on they're told that their
their image of this is probably Trump
brought hundreds of thousands of people
to the Capitol and stood outside and
said go be strong and shut it down
exactly whereas it really happened is
that there was a rally blocks away when
where a bunch of people rallied and
waved Little American flags and then
Trump while he was still speaking people
went to the Capitol yeah and the people
that were breaking in they were breaking
windows at the Capitol 15 minutes before
Trump stopped speaking who were those
people this guy Ray Epps that's been in
the news lately he he and his crew were
taking down all the fencing and all the
signs that said do not enter restricted
area they took down all that fencing so
that when the people walked from the
speech to the Capitol Building they
didn't know that they were entering a
restricted area and a lot of the
defendants are charged with that
entering a restricted area and they said
that we didn't see anything that said it
was restricted is there video of Rey and
other people removing those signs I've
seen some of it it's not in our movie
but I've seen what I'm concerned about
is how defects in the future will start
twisting video but for now video seems
to be a pretty good document of evidence
evidence kind of but I know deep fakes
are real yeah they're they're they are
real and
what do we do about them
well I don't know well but but here's
the problem I mean people are talking
about deep fakes but we have that
technology is not far along enough for
us to make the argument if it is that
far along uh we don't know about it as
far as we are aware that technology is
not far along enough for something like
this to be faked but even with the
actual real video evidence that is there
and a valuable people still buy into the
narrative yeah they won't look at it
they won't they will not take that in
no yeah I agree it's like
continue your point I'm sorry I did not
mean to interrupt no well they just
won't look at the they won't look at the
video whether it's fake or not if it
doesn't support their narrative they
just this past week they just released
three more angles of Ashley Babbitt's
death that were taken from different
places in the hall and you can see
Ashley Babbitt was actually telling the
people breaking the windows to stop that
stop doing that Ashley Babbitt was
talking to the police officers and
saying what are you doing there's why
aren't you calling for reinforcements
there's more people coming up here and
she actually punched a guy that was like
trying to break a window so it's like
this whole narrative about Ashley
Babbitt being some crazed right-wing
Trump supporter is absolutely a total
lie and they knew it from the beginning
what somebody punched through a window
and then she stood up and they saw her
and they fired
yeah well the wind had been broken and
you know I don't I don't know why she
got in that window but there is there is
video of her
telling people to stop breaking stuff
stop doing that talking to the police
saying you need more people up here
you've got to stop this she was on the
side of the police and uh her husband
Aaron says that he he feels like she
she he knew that she was claustrophobic
and he thinks that just sort of the
crush of the people coming up and all
the chaos caused her to panic and to
jump into the window and that's when the
police officer fired and if you watch
the video
bird the the police officer has his gun
trained at that window for like 30 45
seconds yeah before she's even there
probably the window got broken he was
like watch that entrance something's
going to come through there yeah and
while he's standing there pointing the
gun people are right here beside or near
him hitting the window with with two by
fours and trying to break the window and
he never never trains the gun on them
he's pointed right at that one window
that sounds to me like
um
he was angry at the person who broke the
window and wanted them to suffer
that would be my assessment that because
he didn't feel threatened obviously
otherwise he'd focus on the other side
of things but I you know my my
assumption just my assumption is that he
sees he sees someone smash the window
and he goes That's son of a and he pulls
his gun he's like come on do it I've
never been in combat before yeah but me
yeah no I never well Ashley was not the
one that broke the window she no I know
yeah so that's why he had his gun drawn
that the full time because he wanted
whoever broke that window for whatever
they did he was going to get him yeah
and so when she came in she's the one
who got the bullet yeah maybe yeah so
how do how do you you know I think what
we see when you know you you make the
movie capital punishment you said you
just said your agent wouldn't even watch
it
what's happening is a natural sorting
algorithm is occurring people who are
willing to say challenge I I will
challenge my perceptions and that's why
you have people like Bridget fedesy you
know politically homeless now more
aligned with like intellectual dark web
types conversing with Ben Shapiro
conservatives because these are all
people who are willing to be wrong right
and have their perception challenged
what's being sorted between it's being
sorted between two groups those who
don't want out who just want to be told
what to think and those who are more
inquisitive more Discerning I mean I've
said uh some something similar to the uh
to this before there's the the
uninitiated and the more Discerning the
people who don't watch the news who
don't investigate and the people who do
what is your view like so so knowing
what you know having to fire your own
agent where do you think all this is
going to lead to with what they're doing
with law enforcement January 6 committee
and the fact that regular people are
refusing to even learn the truth where
do you think it goes
well uh you mean in terms of the
government they're never going to give
this narrative up they're never going to
stop and what they're doing to these
defendants now is railroading them into
please plea deals you know most of them
are charged with you're facing 28 years
you go before a DC jury that's 96
percent Democrat I don't like your
chances if you plead guilty to this one
little felony
then you know you maybe do six months or
maybe even you just get probation but
you can't vote anymore you don't can't
own a firearm and they are they're
basically
by doing this they are neutralizing a
whole group of people that disagree with
them and the intention that they're
trying to spread a ripple through the
community
of you know by per by Prosecuting these
people so publicly they're going to turn
they're sending the message that don't
don't ever be one of these people or
we'll do this to you so I think the
government is never going to give that
up they're going to run that into the
ground and the only thing we can do is
try to fight that you just had something
very scary um you go before a jury
that's 96 Democrat
we can't function as a constitutional
republic if there are two tribes and I
mean that literally and they will put
you in prison if you're in the opposing
tribe yeah and and another thing about
that DC system is that you have to be
licensed to practice law in DC
you can't like if you get arrested in
Florida and you have a good lawyer you
can't bring him with you unless he's you
know licensed to practice in DC so all
these lawyers they're all D.C residents
96 percent of them are Democrats too and
they literally hate the people that
they're defending they want them to go
to jail and so these these these
court-appointed attorneys are really
working for the government to try to
punish these people that dared stand up
to the to the Democrat Party they
suppose the judicial system isn't
supposed to be nonpartisan I believe
it's supposed to isn't that the point so
when did that change right after it got
formed it's it's cultural enforcement
it it used to be when we were a cohesive
nation that people viewed each other as
Americans people people took jury duty
more seriously and now because of the
overt tribalism of the culture War we I
I said in reference to Pennsylvania it
takes it shows what's happening here now
in Pennsylvania when the Republicans
said hey this Universal mail-in voting
law is unconstitutional the judge's
response was you're a republican so you
lose and I'm not exaggerating yeah he
said your guy lost and now you're coming
and suing
his guy he's an individual bringing a
lawsuit his political party is
irrelevant to the material Well turns
out afterwards oh you are right it was
unconstitutional but the judge was
partisan yeah and now you have this
ruling of unconstitutionality
unconstitutionality
it's a it's Republican judges saying
it's unconstitutional and Democrats
saying it is
if we're at the point and we are if if
this is how the country is going to work
if you're a republican if you're right
winger and you advocate for a right-wing
cause in DC you will go to prison
because they will view bro well they had
that last rally I didn't go to because
of what you're saying now I'm saying if
you if you do something that is
construed as a crime I'm not saying like
literally walking down the street
they're going to come and arrest you I'm
saying if you are in a protest and
advocating for something if I'll put it
this way if you brought a boat down to
DC to protest uh abortion
yeah they're gonna lock you up they're
gonna throw the book at you whereas when
Extinction Rebellion does it it's a slap
on the risk clear it out tow it out and
then send them out there you know I
didn't go to the Robert Malone big
speech in like I think it's February
23rd or no it was a month ago or
something three weeks ago and I I I'm
still I'm almost kicking myself because
I didn't go out of fear I was afraid
that the government was going to Stage a
false flag and then arrest a bunch of
people and like I don't want to live in
Terror of my own government and that's
intentional that's what they're trying
to do is make everybody scared that's
that's why they're doing this to these
people that's why the overwhelming show
of force in their little Suburban
neighborhoods handcuffing their wives
and daughters that's what they're doing
and even even me after I went on January
6 and I shot a bunch of iPhone stuff and
just like a tourist I was afraid to tell
anybody that I went right after it
happened because I was like I'm not
going to post these pictures because the
FBI might look through the pictures and
find somebody you know in the show in
the crowd behind me or something it's
like it was such a
a pervasive attitude of like they're
they're coming after us you know right
and that is intentional yeah I think
you're right about them making an
example of the people who were involved
in January 6 because I think that's what
they're doing with Joe Rogan right now
they're like if we can get the biggest
guy and make an example of him and I
wanted to say too this talk about the
jury is making me wonder if this is what
drives a national divorce I don't know
that there's a way to coexist in a world
where if you get arrested for something
like a traffic ticker or something in DC
and you have to go before a court you
know for a fact that they're going to
throw a book at you gonna throw the book
at you because they disagree with your
politics how do we go on like that I
don't see that as being sustainable and
and National divorce always will lead to
full and Civil War that doesn't end well
yeah well so so what are your thoughts
on that there's been um there was a
period where we had a few uh a few
experts in security say oh Civil War is
possible I became particularly bullish
on it saying I think writing at the
direction but now we're actually getting
Democrat personalities the guardian put
out an article saying the Civil War has
already begun we're in it you've got the
Washington Post now saying the same
thing when you know when we talk about
the courts making their rulings based on
political party it's scary and then you
come to us and say oh and also the
juries themselves are comprised of
individuals who are tribal partisans
sounds to me like
Civil War
well I think the reason that they're
talking about this the Democrats that
are talking about Civil War it's it's
honest that's what they want
that's what they want they're trying to
sell this idea that everybody who went
to Washington on January 6 is some sort
of crazed violent you know
insurrectionist seditionist who wants to
start a Civil War and create you know
that's that's the narrative that they're
selling so I I agree yeah you want to
know why
what's the one way you get rid of the
Constitution
Marshall Civil War yeah Civil War you
can't you you can't get rid of the
Constitution through any means that
exists within the current government the
government would have to be in some way
split fractured or altered so if there
was mass rioting and they came out and
said we need the Insurrection act
martial law you can't get rid of the
Constitution if they're even under
Bush's Presidential Directive 51 you
can't get rid of the constitution in a
civil war
the Constitution is gone emergency right
the direct emergency doesn't do it
directive 51 is terrifying is it in
place right now yes I was reading about
it last night and it's saying like if
there's any issue anywhere yeah it that
like economic or environmental any like
severe issue they say it's like the word
severe is in there and who defines that
the president apparently that they can
just what is it like morph all power I
didn't I didn't go so far on it last
night but is it that they could morph
all powers under one branch yes
government are you familiar with
Presidential Directive 51 no uh it's not
been tested it may just be a stupid
statement made by Bush it's been revised
several times under the previous
presidents I think even Trump may have
revised it uh basically says that if
there's any kind of disaster anywhere in
the world the president has the
authority to dissolve the government and
reform it under a single a single Branch
a constitutional government so it would
have to abide by the original you know
rules and um it would the the three
branches of government would be
organized by uh would be controlled by
the national continuity coordinator
under the executive branch
they could try it it might go to the
courts but it's an interesting
circumstance when one branch asserts the
authority of the other two and then one
of those branches by which they're
subject subjugated by this other Branch
says we reject your Authority
it doesn't really make sense how that
would play out like if the executive
branch says you report to us now and the
court says we hereby decree we don't
yeah well the guys with guns are going
to show up and say yes you do yeah and
that's that's a power created by Bush
and there's been other versions of it
but it's been updated several times it's
not a coincidence the executive branch
has the word execute in it well that's
what it means for yeah not only to make
something happen to execute the plan but
also to execute someone that's yes
literally what the executive branch does
crazy they're the ones with the guns who
go out and enforce the law I thought
they were supposed to execute the law
yeah well sure not execute the people
but I mean well that's why they're
trying to take the guns too exactly part
of it you know and they want to make
sure that we can't
defend ourselves if they decide to
attack well let's be honest if if they
did we we have seen things like Waco and
uh Ruby Ridge Ruby Ridge
most people would just smile and put
their hands behind their back and go
along wherever they were supposed to be
going and that's what happened in uh
let's let's use the most the most talked
about Trope and cliche Nazi Germany
there were a lot of people who at a
certain point just said it's getting bad
we got to get out of here
but most people just said it can't
happen here yep until it did and uh a
lot of people you know I was I've been
reading more and more about it for
obvious reasons I've also been reading
about the Spanish Civil War people they
jumped to the house knock on the door
and say for your safety you're coming
with us get in the cart and they'd be
like okay let me grab my things and
they'd say okay and they'd take the
people off some you know often without
their things just no no take your family
you're coming it's for your own safety
you have to do it and people just said
yes we're seeing that Australia yep not
like they're taking people in Australia
to you know work camps to to rot them
out till they die but it's crazy to me
that there's there's a video out of
Australia where the cops show up to a
guy's house unannounced and they say sir
you have tested positive for covid and
you are now being indefinitely
quarantined get in the van and he goes
all right mate and he just hops in the
van and I'm just like wow
great yeah that Germans used typhus as
an excuse they said a lot of the Jewish
population had typhus I don't know if
that was the reason for taking them on
the trains but maybe those are like for
your own safety we don't want you to get
sick it was one of the propaganda things
they were claiming about oh these these
ghettos are dirty and they have typhus
so they have to be taken to special
facilities and we know how that went and
you know look we look back at history I
don't think history is going to repeat
itself history Rhymes and so you know
people who are ignorant will be like oh
that can't happen here or that won't
happen and it's like probably not no to
be honest some form of it will
well see that
they don't have to actually murder you
now like they did yeah they don't have
to murder you and dispose of your body
now they can just digitally erase you
they can just neutralize You by by
removing your voice from the community
so it's it'll happen differently it's
like what they're doing with Rogan you
know you're you're just you have to be
careful or the government will just
erase your point of view demonize you
destroy your ability to to express
yourselves if you have wrong thing if
you have a bad opinion these ostracize
people throw them out of the country and
not let them back in but now that was
before electricity and telephones and
stuff yeah they don't even have to do
that now it just shuts you down well
that's why it's called character
assassination the entire idea is you
neutralize the threat that somebody
poses by telling the truth or by stating
some facts that you find to be
inconvenient and um or by lying it's you
know or by lying sure you can you can
perform a character assassination on
someone who has actually lied but yeah
it's very frightening and at some point
you wonder how much they really have to
do to cover anything up how much
information they really need to hide
from the people it seems to me that all
you really have to do is attack and
character assassinate the people who are
speaking the truth and then even if the
facts seem fishy to the general public
and they're not willing to buy into your
narrative they're going to be too scared
to say anything they take like a wait
and watch approach and if the person
ends up getting busted it almost doesn't
matter if they were right or wrong
they're like I don't want that to happen
to me right that's why I've been saying
for a while about the police
you look at what's going on up in
Ontario when that cop arrests that 78
year old man here's the crazy thing so
there's this viral video where 78 year
old man's honking his horn the cop
arrests him this was before honking was
banned so this is just some cop deciding
to bully an old man who honked his horn
you look at the cops who are seizing
gasoline you look at the cops who are
defending antifa they don't care they
literally don't care and it's crazy when
I meet cops who are like I'm a big fan
of the show and I'm just like I hope
you're one of the good ones because we
got too many bad ones the capital police
are all some really evil people I mean
you look at what they were saying on TV
how they were lying about things I get
that there was a bad fight and there was
riding and stuff I'm not discrediting
that or anything like that but it's
crazy how they're willing to just say
the most absurd and ridiculous
statements I was the next day I was you
know the craziest thing is they're like
the stress the left is claiming the
stress of it resulted in officers taking
their own lives and stuff like that I'm
like come on man you know we don't know
why those offices some officers did take
their own lives yeah and I don't know if
that's related or not but it's just such
a dirty dirty thing they're they're
they're milking this as much as they can
I will tell you this you know I'm most
frustrated with the people who actually
ride and fought with cops and tried to
break and literally broken the building
because it's just like watching people
you know it's like it's like watching
someone walking down the road and
they're like on the side of a cliff and
then they look to their left and start
to walk towards the cliff and you're
like please don't do that and they go
I'll be fine
like Alex Jones was there saying stop
don't go inside don't do it then listen
to him a lot of young young people
thinking they're going to reload their
save game if something goes wrong
well if you see in the movie you just
see we have all these people suspicious
looking people exhorting the crowd come
this way you know get in here go into
the capitol break in you know they're
just constantly berating these people
screaming at them and you also have the
Capitol Police who are in many instances
the aggressors here they they were
firing flashbangs and tear gas grenades
and pepper spray into the middle of the
crowd that's what's driving them forward
rather than trying to keep them from
coming forward they were just firing
into the middle of the crowd and you
know the stuff that happened in the
tunnel it's now being revealed that
Roseanne Boylan was probably beaten to
death by a police officer command was
probably like just we can't contain this
just get them in the building we'll bust
them all later well I don't know about
that but in Ferguson one of the nights I
was down at the riots people had stopped
writing and protesting it was it was uh
maybe like the fifth night they were
just dancing in the street playing music
One Cop from the police line at the at
the far end of West Florissant
casually walked up pulled a flashbang
and just threw it into a crowd of
dancing people and that immediately
started a riot people then started
screaming running towards the police
yelling and then all of a sudden people
who didn't live in the neighborhood
started smashing windows and stealing
stuff the cops did that so when I say
abolish the police I'm telling you this
right now
you look at what is going on with the
purging of wrong think they're they're
they start by saying if you're if you're
unvaccinated there's a mandate you're
fired well guess what only the people
that fall in line is do it and do as
they're told are gonna remain on as
police they're going to remain in
military then they're going to put those
National Guardsmen in your schools teach
your kids like they're doing in New
Mexico they're having them Drive school
buses in Massachusetts they're going to
replace more and more jobs because of
the emergency and the labor shortage of
the National Guard and they've already
purged the ranks of anybody who would
disobey who disobey The Narrative you
don't want to live under that boot
so your best bet right now is just hey
call the bluff of the left yay abolish
the police and then when they're like no
no no I thought you wanted to I think
it's funny when the left like they freak
out
because I tweeted about the police and
they're like well I mean but but he
wants militias and I'm like that's
literally what you asked for yeah you
said Community Police what do you think
militias are yeah what do they think was
gonna well social workers actually Tim
is what they want it's because they
don't really want to abolish the police
they want control of the police yes no
that's exactly what it is and the police
with a smile on their face our face are
putting boots on people's necks and it's
funny you know you mentioned the um the
police officers and yes there were
officers harmed on January 6th that's
very unfortunate uh however I should
point out that according to the major
cities Chiefs Association 72 of major
city law enforcement agencies had
officers harmed during the BLM rights 72
that is a massive number and you know I
don't care
you know I literally don't care that
they were injured I mean I I think it's
horrible when everyone gets injured if
you're insulted if you're gonna show up
to attila's gym and arrest the owners or
try and prosecute them and seize money
from their bank accounts you want
sympathy from me the police in this
country have no sympathy for that guy no
no I'm just uh look man there are there
are small offices and departments I'll
I'll put it this way sheriff's offices
with duly elected law enforcement oh I
think they're great they still do bad
things there was a there was a woman who
was arrested for opening her Cafe during
lockdown and it was a sheriffs who came
and arrested are the deputies yeah
that's that's bad but these big city
police departments I'm referring to
specifically they they they they they
did nothing while the riots were
happening it's true and when it happened
I said well look I don't blame them for
defending these businesses from people
who won't support them but then they
turn around and became the vandals who
locked down their businesses and Destroy
these people's lives so I sit back at
these cities and I'm like y'all deserve
each other but here's my main point
if the police departments have purged of
wrong thinkers and all that's left are
going to be those who toe the line
that's what we've seen over the past two
years the people the cops who stayed on
during the BLM riots after all the
disrespect that's that's that's a great
mental test psychological test are you
willing to endure extreme pressure where
everyone hates you where we won't
support you and you shut your mouth and
get on your knees and these officers who
stayed said yes that's a good sign for a
despot they then said okay now you got
to inject yourself with something and a
bunch of them were like nah that's too
far for me but a lot of them said yes
sir may I have another yeah and they got
their second shot and their boosters
and now at the point where you think
that these departments will defend your
right to Liberty no no certainly if
there ever was a group of people who
were going to uh who are going to Goose
step to the to the to the Barking uh
marching orders of a despot it is the
modern police that have remained through
all of this refusing to stand up for
themselves refusing to stand up for
others falling in line over overtly
illegal orders and rule by decree I'm
not gonna defend any of those people
yeah when you talk about illegal orders
because it's called law enforcement so
if you're getting illegal orders from a
top-down Authority and you're the law
enforcement you're supposed to not
follow the illegal order and stay lawful
they don't care about what's legal they
don't know what to do there have been
many instances in my life where I've had
cops tell me that something was illegal
and what wasn't you know New York is a
great example that's a frozen Zone the
cop told me and my friends and during
Occupy Wall Street and I'm like you made
that up it's not even a little Frozen
zones they just made it up one day and
you see what's going on with the BLM
mural painted in New York City the 27
officers who defended it on an illegal
seizure of taxpayer funds for a
political message yep and the police
were like boss told me to do it I'll
arrest anybody who opposes me yo we're
in dark dark times now man agreed I
think um but in terms of maybe this is a
small white pole but I think there's a
white pill here uh and despite all of
the media propaganda a large number of
the American people a large swath of the
population are still seeing through this
according to erasmussen report survey
that was done back in July only about 50
percent of the population who was
surveyed at that time supported Nancy
Pelosi's January 6th committee and
investigating that whereas two-thirds of
American citizens surveyed wanted an
investigation into the 2020 BLM riots so
no matter how much they're lying about
this or trying to call this an
Insurrection and tell us to ignore that
the majority of the American people do
see the truth about it so we're getting
this let's jump to the story we have and
we'll see what's going on in the U.S CBS
news reports U.S truckers planning
protest Convoy perhaps starting in La
for Super Bowl DHS warns that's right
the Department of Homeland Security is
warning an American Convoy May begin if
it's anything like what we saw in Canada
it will work it'll be very effective and
uh
you know probably end up winning and
they're already they're already starting
to pull back on the Mandate so I've been
so funny if you just went on to the next
story right after like I said we should
do that thank you very much but uh but I
am wondering if this is even a real
story
I I know there have been conversations
about locking down the Super Bowl but
that seems weird to me almost like the
idea was seated specifically to ruin the
freedom Convoy because right now regular
people don't know like I'm talking about
average people sitting at home of which
there are very few because I think most
people are polarized they're like I
don't know a whole lot about what's
going on with that Convoy thing but the
the manipulation the propaganda has
mostly failed you go on Reddit and
people are like they're just working
class dudes they're drivers the
propaganda is not working well you want
to piss off regular people shut down the
Super Bowl hmm
and I'm I'm suspicious of you know dhs's
warnings it's like yeah you know I think
that it it's high it's likely that they
could be just sort of trying to say
there's a threat out there that that's
not really there to make it seem like
well you know those extreme people those
truckers they're going to try to kill
your Super Bowl public warnings just
don't make a lot of sense to me if a
military comes out and it's like China
has you know we think that China's UFO
is like come on dude what are you
telling me for yeah I don't you would
only tell the people that need it's a
need to know thing they would tell La
law enforcement about this they wouldn't
in surrounding areas they wouldn't be
telling the public did you see that clip
of the journalist arguing with the uh
was it was it Dan price was it was the
name I don't know I remember his name
he's the uh the Canadian guy no no no
the journalist talking to an American uh
official about Russia's Russia's false
flag attack because the U.S keeps saying
over and over again Russia is going to
Stage a false flag and then he's like
what proof do you have they're like well
we issued a transcript that's something
you said happened
and then he goes crisis actors are you
kid this is Alex Jones stuff yeah and
then he goes on to mention I think like
the wmds and like the war in Iraq I'm
like that guy just snapped something
happened to me woke up and the narrative
broke yeah he was just out of The Matrix
yeah and and the the the the government
guy was going you know what are you on
Putin's side yeah I just it's so funny
how we return to that too I remember
during the 2012 election when Mitt
Romney said something about Russia being
a growing threat and of course he would
he's like an establishment swamp
creature but the response from the left
was oh my goodness isn't this hysterical
you know the 80s called they want their
villain back and then in 2016 when we're
even more removed from that era it's
Russia Russia Russia what a strange
villain it's like we were joking about
this in in Burn After Reading when she
she wants to sell the information to the
Russians and everyone in the CIA is like
the Russians yeah why yeah like what
would they yeah well also because if if
you're not familiar with that movie the
information was nothing it's also the
information was it was nothing like the
Russians like what I got a question for
you guys
if uh a bunch of Truckers
showed up um in DC and then something
happened that a mass casualty event took
the lives of these truckers how do you
think the left the establishment left
and many leftists would react
mocking uh they would laugh until there
was no one to bring them their food yeah
exactly
yeah you absolutely would laugh they
would celebrate it yeah that's that's
pretty scary
yeah I'd say they deserved it yeah maybe
look at what they do to Ashley Babbitt
you know it's like sometimes you get
glimpses of humanity from people like
Jake Tapper and stuff so maybe people
would be like this is it this is the
moment that it went too far well I guess
you know sometimes the brain slug that
infected his mind and took over his body
loses control he's able to break out
just all of a sudden on CNN he's like I
love all of you honey I love you and
you're making me think of him the Kent
State shooting in 1970 May 4 Kent State
I went to Kent State and it was a big
deal on campus these four there was a
big crowd of students protesting Vietnam
and then the National Guard came out to
try and quiet them down they were
throwing rocks at the National Guard
they opened fire on the crowd and killed
four injured others and it was a huge
National just a tragedy and it it
basically was the beginning of the end
of Vietnam Neil Young song yeah and uh
Buffalo Springfield yeah well Neal was
in Buffalo Springfield yeah oh and
interesting yeah but the uh the um for
what it's worth that's such a good yeah
it's a great song but the people who got
who lost their lives weren't protesters
I'm pretty sure wait yeah Neil was in
Buffalo but when they when the real
estate happened yeah it was bystanders
it's just people who were on campus
walking by one guy there was also
injuries one guy took a bullet through
his his wrist I think and it paralyzed I
would sit on the hill and envision all
the people and just think about it
sometimes that's good it's crazy man one
thing here in I mean this almost in some
ways makes it more frightening but I'll
issue a caveat to this idea of left-wing
people
hypothetically laughing in the situation
and we seem to believe that many of them
would I think there's also an argument
to be made that those among them who
have some level of of empathy for their
opposition and don't necessarily hate
everyone who stands in their way would
still feel pressure to not care about
the loss of life because as soon as they
stood up and said these are human beings
they'd be rejected because that's
exactly what happens to them when they
say that about The Unborn or any other
group that the left is okay with the
death of zombie horde yeah yeah it's
it's it's mindless you know know
that we're talking about this with your
film your agent you know getting fired
these are people who don't care about
the truth they don't want to hear the
truth they just want to hate yeah they
want to be a part of it imagine a mob of
people with pitchforks and torches
they don't know they don't care they're
just going to do whatever the mob does
I've watched it happen in real time I've
I've been in these major protests where
I've seen people lose it and attack
random people I was in San Jose during
that Infamous Trump rally I felt I
filmed a guy getting smacked in the back
of the head with a bag of what we think
were rocks oh wow went viral overnight
and there was also a guy who got beat up
because they just someone decided to
beat him up and the mob just said that's
the guy we're beating up turns out he
was a part of the mob there was a kid
some 16 year old kid was walking on the
street someone started attack Chase
running after him the whole mob chased
after him it's it's absolutely insane
but that's what we're dealing with
the I I suppose I'll put it this way
if you've got liberals conservatives
moderates you know traditionalists
progressives
that are all in alignment but they all
agree with liberty and and being
inquisitive so there's like uh Jimmy
Dore Jimmy dors Progressive and Lefty
but he believes in the truth so we like
the guy you know because you know we
disagree on politics across you know all
day and night it's clear that what
divides us is not policy it is simply
there is a a mob of people that want to
be a mob and there's everyone else who
want to live and understand and solve
problems those are the two groups that
are clashing right now
and the left is kind of the the way
they've been brought to this point by
the Democrat Party and the leaders in
that movement is is they've been told
over and over again you are the good
people
and it's that self-righteousness of like
that Surety and that self-righteousness
those people over there are bad they
hate gays they hate black people they
hate everybody you know you're one of
the good people so no matter what they
say we we have to remain above them I
was having a deep conversation last
night um about this and about after 9
11. all of a sudden this Narrative of
Good and Evil started getting shoved
down my throat by George Bush and
everybody else around him and it was
like they're bad you're good we're the
heroes God's on our side good versus
evil good versus evil then superhero
movies started coming out good versus
evil where people are brainwashed they
think it's good versus evil now it's
terrifying
but it is good versus evil trust me it's
not Ian would that be there's
destruction and creation but all the
other stuff is perspective there it's
just you're just wrong I understand I
want you to think that they want you
polarized I understand what you're
saying but uh someone swatted us and we
got swatted twice and why would we get
swatted a second time is it evil to try
and kill someone because they have
conversations you don't like
well like I just said man there's
creation and destruction and then it
depends on who you ask if I'm gonna give
you a different answer than everyone
else though so give me your answer
what's the question again yeah it's from
what you said killing someone for what
trying to get someone kill a group of
people killed because they have
conversations you don't like oh for me
that I think of that as terribly now now
now who would disagree with you
the people trying to kill the person and
having the conversation well to them
you're the evil I mean that's all
perspective and who's telling the story
who's in control of the narrative so I
agree with you that people have
different perspectives but some
perspectives are wrong that's the point
and they would say the same thing and
they would be wrong it's okay to say I'm
right now but it's okay to be wrong also
yeah not but not any longer than you
have to be as soon as you get the new
information that shows that your
previously held assumptions were
incorrect you have an obligation to
accept those I think
99.9 of humanity has agreed that killing
people for no reason is wrong and uh a
smaller a a slightly lar uh large single
digit percentage probably agrees with
preemptive murder for the sake of
ideology like if the most you know I
mean the president's so dangerous it's
okay to get rid of like 80 000 citizens
yeah Communists tend to be you know
that's the American government American
government did that the Democratic
Republic of the United States
citizens
that's evil it is evil yes
people are like hey the end justify the
means because that guy's so dangerous
and sometimes that guy is so dangerous
like Hitler Ian Ian you are incorrect on
the right and the left there is populist
Unity that invading foreign countries
and blowing people up is wrong what
about not I mean what about firebombing
Dresden to stop Hitler
you're you're towards the evil you're
talking about a response
so like if some guy in a house
starts breaking in other people's homes
and killing people and then we go and
he's in in one of the houses so we're
like the only thing we can do to stop
this guy is burn the house down but you
know might hurt somebody else like this
guy's already killed so many people
that's called the difficult this is good
because I think that you're talking
about individual one-on-one interactions
there now we can start to get a Nuance
of Good and Evil but in the in the
society it's dangerous to slap that
label around well yeah I mean whether
you're talking about like firebombing
Dresden or firebombing Tokyo or nuclear
uh bombs being dropped in Hiroshima and
Nagasaki you can agree that one
particular side of the conflict was
correct and had to win while also saying
this was objectively morally evil you
should not make civilians a target of
warfare that's a position you can hold
no no you're not saying that you're
saying like actually they shouldn't have
done that they were I was on their side
or am on their side but I don't think
that that's something they should have
done you can agree with you can side
with somebody and still say but don't do
that you're not pledging like undying uh
agreement with everything they do or
have done let me let me let me explain
something for you again
if I say I've reviewed as much evidence
as I can from what happened on January 6
and there are some people who did some
some things that were very wrong and
should be held accountable and there are
some people that are being harassed and
even tortured by the government and
that's wrong I'm I'm trying to be as
objective and honest as possible to be
fair and just to as many people as I can
so that we can all live in harmony
trying to help people flourish stopping
the bad stopping the pain stopping the
suffering and promoting growth is
typically a good thing
when you have other organizations that
lie on purpose to to create destruction
and cause pain and suffering and then
lie to convince people that we're the
evil ones that's evil
I know ma'am but now we're talking about
like living living like living and lying
and knowing you're lying and acting
anyway
I I know this phone is made by slaves I
know that and I'm doing it anyway yeah
and and so what am I living a lie just
walking around like do you acknowledge
they don't think people yeah like if
they were here I would I wouldn't be
like La Dee Da I'd be like free these
guys but they're they're out of sight
out of mind that's why I know it but Ian
but so but what I'm catching it I think
you actually believe so firmly and
deeply in Morality that you're arguing
for moral consistency but you're seeing
that as saying that morality doesn't
exist I really think on some level you
do believe in Good and Evil you just
aren't acknowledging it I really think
you do because you get really upset when
a person is hypocritical about their
moral values and why would that be
upsetting for you if good and evil
weren't real I think you're right I I do
believe I am good but I am a product of
my parents and what they told me good is
but did you choose to accept that
definition and have you chosen to act on
it
because that is your own free will yeah
it's not just your yeah it jived with
Society so I accepted it is that why you
accepted it basically are you gonna tell
me you've never made a moral decision
because you thought it was the right
thing to do and not because it jogged
with Society I've done that too exactly
exactly so you can't just say well it's
all relative and it's all my parents at
some point you made choices
yeah let's let's talk about the movie
industry yeah yeah because there was
something I wanted to bring up actually
in all of this context and it's the
response we saw from The Establishment
in the left over Alec Baldwin and the
shooting because I've I've I've went you
know gone off on the Alec Baldwin thing
many a Time
based on everything I've already read
about what happened with Alec Baldwin
for those aren't familiar he was on a
movie set he had a live gun a single
action revolver
um I can't remember what ammo type it
was I don't think it was 45 I'm not sure
but uh
he shot and killed cinematographer put
pointed the gun at her pulled the hammer
back then they say the gun went off
killed her he said he didn't know that
she got shot for 45 minutes which is to
imply that while he was holding the gun
and pointing at her pulling the hammer
back and then it banged and went off in
his hand which for which he felt The
Recoil
when she collapsed to the ground dying
he simply walked away and didn't bother
ask what was going on he did not even
know she must have just fainted he said
so in my opinion based on the story
they've tried blaming the armorer who
was on the set uh at first you know we
were like wow it sounds like an accident
once we got the real details
I think it is more likely that Alec
Baldwin was extremely angry he's a
hothead
and he shot and killed this woman I
think he wasn't he was just in a fit of
rage I don't know how you could you
could argue that this circuitous all
these events took place that
coincidentally landed a live bullet in a
gun where the Seer was broken so the gun
went off
but uh
Nick you actually worked with that
armorer
yeah when I saw that uh you know I was
reading about the Alec Baldwin thing
when it first broke and it said you know
the armor there it was her second movie
and I was like oh my gosh it's Hannah I
mean you know I'd done the old way with
Nicholas Cage back in August since he
was the armor on that film and
you know I she seemed competent to me
she taught me how to load an old
Winchester and you know I mean she she
did a good job as far as I can tell I
didn't have any problems with her but
those the thing about the Alec Baldwin
thing that makes absolutely no sense
is number one how did a live round get
in there I mean I've never been on a set
where there was a live round I mean I I
just never happened and the other thing
that occurred to me too in reading the
steps he was handed the gun by a first
A.D who said it's a cold gun
that's not how you do it the armorer
brings the gun to you shows you
everything that's in the gun if you're
firing the gun it's you know the armorer
will say you have two rounds here and
then the blanks you pull the trigger
twice and then it's done there's no more
bullets in the gun so you know exactly
what's in the gun all at all times and
even if the even if they say cut they
come and they take the gun away from you
for 30 seconds
when the armor brings a gun back he does
the same thing he shows you every single
time
I don't know how in the world
you know that that happened without
Baldwin with the first ad just handing
him a gun Alec Baldwin not looking in
the gun
and and then pulling the trigger you
worked with this uh this Hannah this
armorer and when you worked with her she
showed you the gun and explained to you
the ammo that all that stuff as you
described yeah well and and the other
thing that I read about the Alec Baldwin
shooting is that Hannah the armorer was
not in the room
because
sag has these coveted restrictions and
people have designations of a b or c and
if you're in the B group or the C group
you can't be indoors with people in the
a group
so Hannah was not allowed to be in that
church
when the the he was using the gun but it
sounds like the production team is
liable of some sort of felonious
activity oh absolutely incompetence if
nothing else and the other thing too
that was rehearsal he was just you know
they weren't shooting the scene every
time I've never done a rehearsal with a
gun It's A rubber gun it's not they
don't even give you the real gun until
you're actually shooting the scene where
you have to see the real gun I've heard
that they were like had live rounds and
they were Target practicing between
shoot days and takes and stuff I don't
know how to confirm that or deny that
but I've heard that way I've heard that
too I mean that's very very uh that's
not that's not normal and so that's what
they're doing and I can also believe it
like out in the in the west out in the
desert a bunch of them just kind of like
20 people making a movie on the Fly kind
of like having fun drinking beer at
night yeah and a lot of it too was that
you know he he had had some crew
problems or whatever the crew was a lot
of the crew had quit because of the
conditions on the set they were previous
uh discharges you know accidental
discharges that they said the set wasn't
safe a lot of the crew had quit and so
he'd replace them with less experienced
people so there's a big convergence of a
whole lot of incompetence that went in
there but to your point
I don't know how a live round got in
that gun I mean and and for him to be if
it's like you said if he was there he's
got that experience yeah and not just
that it isn't that there was simply one
live round and one gun one time you're
saying there were multiple discharges on
set that made crew feel unsafe yeah and
this is not live round discharges this
is just okay this is just blanks but you
know whenever a gun's going to be fired
you say fire in the hole everybody knows
because you kind of get the ear
protection out whatever you know there
were just a couple of times when the gun
went off and everybody went what the
hell what are you doing you know I was
the one saying that I've heard that they
were doing target practice with live
rounds on set and they were a mix of
live rounds and dummy rounds and they I
heard that too I've been reading about
it and I don't know how to confirm or
deny it but I mean come on there was a
live round on set so sometimes they will
usually it's a different day but if
you're shooting
like if you're shooting a lot in a movie
they will take you to a range and let
you feel what the recoil is on a real
gun so that when you're acting and
you're shooting blanks you can act like
you know you're actually firing the real
thing so that happened but that's
usually like if that happens it's on a
different day and it's it it totally
separate from I mean if they're just
walking around back and you know soaking
some cans or something that's that's not
acceptable the response we end up seeing
strangely is tribal people defending
Alec Baldwin in the establishment left
people criticizing him in the
anti-establishment right and it
seemingly has nothing to do with
politics I mean Alec Baldwin is you know
Democrat you know activists and all that
stuff maybe that's a big reason but what
happened with Alec Baldwin is not
political
yet here we are well I think the only
thing people see is political is the
aftermath of that him getting away with
it and he's getting away with it because
he's part of the left-wing establishment
you know that they they don't want to go
after him because just like you were
saying earlier the people in DC are
going to be putting for in front of
democrat jurors who will convict them
Alec Baldwin will never see a day you
think the people are like I I know he
did it and I know he's responsible but I
love his work so much that I don't want
to put him in jail because I want to see
another Alec Baldwin Movie
he's not that great he's not dead I
think it's a tribal but he has zealous
fans well like I'll follow him to hell
and back but what percentage of the
population could that be
like .000
people or something if you saw Team
America World Police you know Alan
Baldwin was the greatest actor in the
world 100
I mean I like his work Backdraft yeah
Beetlejuice yeah great movie fantastic
I've liked him in certain things yeah oh
yeah his talent is undeniable but also
you know that's not what this is about
it should never be about no
took someone's left in my case
it's already you're extremely talented
so one question I'd like to ask you Nick
I'm curious as you were working on this
documentary what was the most
interesting thing you discovered
well when we went into it we the
original title of the movie was the
trouble with free speech because I saw
this as like the government suppressing
free speech and trying to keep these
people from you know deter these people
from Ever coming to Washington and and
making their voices heard again but what
what we wound up discovering is that by
talking to these people who had been
visited by the FBI and the way they were
being treated and the that was the most
shocking thing it's just like every
story in this movie you just can't
believe that this is America
they are coming to these people's houses
these are people that have never been
arrested for anything before in their
lives
and they're 6 a.m SWAT teams 20 rifles
red dots on their chest come out with
your hands up
uh handcuffing their wives and daughters
and breaking down doors and I mean it's
real
terrorist kind of gestapo-like tactics
and as these stories started to pile up
I was just like okay this is this is the
story we have to tell this is this is
this is what this movie's about it's
about how these people are being treated
and why are they being treated that way
and so that you know to to realize that
your government is intentionally
terrorizing
innocent people
only one of the only one of the people
that we interview ever went in the
building and those are the two twin 74
year old grandmothers everybody else is
outside never went inside so we we
started talking about how you had worked
with the armor on on uh from the um the
Alec Baldwin movie Hannah what's her
name I can't remember
yeah so so uh we mentioned you worked
with her you've been in TV shows and
movies
how has it been trying to continue that
career after making a documentary like
this and voting for Trump and you know
have they have that I can't imagine
they're very happy with you well no but
you know I have I've worked in the
business long enough that I have friends
who know who I am and hire me anyway you
know and you know sometimes it's not you
know I don't know I I still continue to
get work here and there it's not as much
as it used to be that may be because I'm
old or or it may be because I'm a
right-wing radical republican
insurrectionist you know I don't know
but I you know like I say I have
relationships that uh you know sustained
me to this day and and I'm also at this
point in my life I'm really much more
interested in pursuing movies that I
want to make that I want to have some
control over and I'm not so much
interested in just like trying to get a
job in somebody else's left-wing garbage
what are you working on now or is there
something you've worked on recently
um well uh Terror on the Prairie is a
movie that's coming out with the Gina
Carano that'll come out June 10th that's
the daily wire movie
um and uh but that's already done I'm
trying to put together some uh movies
that uh a couple of narrative features
that I wrote with a partner Blake Ellis
a one called where I'm bound which is
about Gospel quartet music in the 60s
that's very
sexy subject and um and I'm also trying
there's another documentary I want to
make about the uh
1972 Olympic men's basketball team that
got screwed by the Russians oh wow and
11 of those guys are still alive this is
the 50th Anniversary this year of of
that game and uh all those guys have
refused the silver medal to this day and
the one guy that passed away put it in
his will that no one in his family
can ever take that silver medal because
they were just blatantly cheated out of
the gold medal interesting what's the
story there they uh basically it was a
close game and it's interesting because
uh you know a lot of the best players in
America didn't play that year like Bill
Walton wouldn't play he had just come
out of UCLA and this is before they let
professional players play so it was not
I mean it was a good team but it wasn't
like the best of the best right and so
it was very close game and they replayed
the last three seconds of the game three
times until the Russians won what they
America was up by one point Doug Collins
had hit two free throws with three
seconds left and Russia was taking the
ball out of bounds under uh America's
basket had to go to length of the Court
they played the three seconds the first
time and threw the ball out of bounds
and time ran out and the referee said oh
no he called time out before
before the ball was thrown in and
they're like no no he did nobody called
timeout and then they did it again they
they replayed that three seconds again
some other problem and they had like
well not to tell the whole story but
there were five judges that let them
replay the the three seconds a third
time and on the third time they threw
the ball the link that the court the
Russian Center pushed the American out
of bounds caught the bomb put it in and
they won by one point was it a Soviet uh
judge judges all five of them it was it
well it was no it was two pro-soviet
judges and two uh pro-america judges and
the fifth judge was supposed to be this
judge from Egypt who was Pro who was
pro-western but when the Israeli
athletes were murdered nine days before
this game
Egypt pulled all their athletes out of
the Olympics and that judge was not
there and they put in another judge who
was a Russian well this is a good story
it's a great story it really is it's a
great story because it's it's
geopolitics it's the Cold War it's you
know it's all that stuff and then all
and also with the the killing of the
Israeli athletes at that Olympics it
sort of that's kind of why this story
got forgotten because it wasn't as
important as that you know what's a
budget for a movie like that
well it's a I see it as a four four hour
documentary yeah I could probably make
it about
million 1.5 I could probably how do you
how does a how does a person come across
money like that to make a movie
well you gotta talk you gotta convince
uh investors that you can make some
money with it you know and and you know
a lot of times with a movie like this
you pitch it to ESPN or you pitch it to
Netflix that's the easiest way but to
make it independently you gotta you
gotta and that's what we've been trying
to do because Netflix won't talk to me
are you taking donations to produce the
movie
um we not taking open donations you know
we're not that's complicated process uh
so we're trying to find you know you
spin up like a corporation that like
owns the movie and then that's yeah like
a LLC yeah I just recently found out
that's kind of how Hollywood works is
when they make a movie they make a
corporation that owns the movie and then
they can give like people percentages of
that Corporation right that work on that
movie and every movie kind of has to
have its own company right so yeah but
it's you know I have some people
interested and you know that's that's
something that I would really like to do
soon have you done anything with crypto
see I'm old I don't even know what
crypto is
so I'm talking about crypto I go I don't
know crypto's our savior oh actually
cryptos our tracking mechanism I don't
yeah it's it's the evolution of digital
currency I really I have no literally
when you guys were talking about crypto
before I was like okay I have nothing to
add I don't know I don't even know what
it is it's like an immutable Ledger is
the difference between that and banking
is that there's an online Ledger that
can't supposedly can't be tampered with
so you can everything's there for view
right and decentralized digital banking
right and stores of value different
cryptocurrencies have different
characteristics so they're easier harder
to move and then sometimes you get into
it where certain types of crypto can do
things like on a certain Network you can
give someone one and it'll give you a
thousand views on the network or so
either called smart contracts that they
can build in so that they actually do
things instead of just being like Bland
currency well like how do you buy stuff
with it
um give it to somebody you got to sell
it usually for dollars on coinbase or
something like that or you can trade it
to someone that wants to take it for
currency it's as simple as this I uh I
would like those glasses sir and I'll
give you a rock for it okay so I've got
if I've got an account with five crypto
in it I could be like hey that jacket's
mighty fine I'll give you a crypto for
it yeah just generic I'll say ethereum
and then you'll be like okay and then I
just text it to you you know just
and then how do I but like can I take
that to the 7-Eleven and buy gas with it
no you move it over to your wallet on
this website called coinbase.com or
something like that where and then
they'll buy your ethereum and give you
dollars and it'll direct deposit it into
your bank account uh or something soon
probably in the next you know five ten
years you will be able to go to 7-Eleven
and use crypto Costa Rica just named
Bitcoin their National currency
El Salvador really yeah so they're
they're a crypto economy now and it's
been really great for their cop for
their standard of living no because
Bitcoin is uh uh there's only so many so
it's uh you can't you can't print more
it's mined through a complicated process
and there's only so many that can exist
which means after a long enough period
of time the value can only go up because
the amount of Bitcoin can only go down
yeah well there you go okay yeah
predetermined deflationary currencies
it's pretty cool and then you can Sprint
up as a million infinite amounts of them
currency is going to be way different in
the future I don't think yeah like the
whole idea of yeah current and currency
like that's electrical they're they're
killing the dollar I mean the dollar is
not going to be worth very much very
soon well that's why Ian was saying that
crypto may be our downfall our trap
because I've talked about this before
while I'm a big fan of Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies this this new
decentralized Financial technology it's
all trackable yep you can go online and
search at Bitcoin addresses and see
where the money has come from and where
it's gone so if you post on your website
like here's my Bitcoin address I can
take it I can search it and I can see
where you've put your money you got a
smart enough computer you can track
every single transaction every single
you know everywhere no matter what they
do with it right so uh great reset
Bitcoin seems like it'll work really
well for them to be honest wow yeah
let's go to super chats though if you
haven't already smash that like button
honk that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
go to timcast.com we're gonna have a
members only segment coming up at
timcast.com at about 11 pm so with your
support as members we're able to keep
doing all this work and we'd be
eternally grateful if you would help us
out but now let's read what you all have
to say in the super chats
all right
we got Buck Muskie he says my country
has lost its democracy even if we can
somehow get rid of our authoritarian
leaders how can we as Citizens ever come
back from this Great Divide the
state-funded media has worked so hard to
create we're doomed I would like to say
I think it is about friendship like what
you were saying Nick in Hollywood no
matter what your political things are
you have friends you have a community of
people that know you and love you and
that you love that will work with you no
matter what your political values are
and I think that's going to always be
the case
all right Samuel Pyle says when I try to
log log into timcast.com on Chrome it
has the font white on white background
but if I lock in log in on Brave it does
the normal black on white I don't know
if this is a glitch or Google trying to
censor you I'm a gorilla well good
gorilla sir I don't know either there
have been some bugs because we we
recently did a major upgrade on the site
which is going to streamline the process
and reduce the errors but this could
mean that there are some errors popping
up so uh if you if anybody's having any
issues just email members at timcast.com
and we'll get you set up
all right Jeffrey says Super Bowl
tickets are like ten thousand dollars
corporate AF oh okay is that why they
want to shut down the Super Bowl because
no regular person can go there anyway
but also it's like a do they even want
to shut down the Super Bowl I don't know
we have no clue I mean I enjoy the Super
Bowl not that I'm a big football fan or
anything but Sunday we're gonna be
hanging out we're gonna have wings and
pizza yeah I like a good slant hit your
wide receiver over by the sideline
especially if they can jump over the
cornerback man it's something like
everyone has agreed we're gonna hang out
and eat good food everyone has agreed to
chips dip and wings yeah exactly exactly
how are you going to argue with that
it's Cincinnati in Los Angeles
well I don't even watch the game to be
honest we turn it on and then we eat
wings and everybody hangs out Tim goes I
can't wait for the halftime show I just
love these watch the commercials the
commercials are honestly pretty funny
usually but I feel like they're going to
be woke this year no they were woke last
year they're not gonna stop I was on a
Super Bowl commercial one year I think
it was 2007. are you serious it's the
Orbit Gum commercial where uh the
clipping my nose hairs in the mirror and
then my roommate eats his noodle really
yeah oh it's online it's on YouTube
check it out but we'll write that down I
want to pull that up after the show uh
Super Bowl man so it's a lot of fun um
but the uh but I like the woke
commercials because they're funny yeah
it's hilarious it's like they're it's
like you ever see the movie The Room
yeah you know oh hi Mark or whatever
like that's what it's like it's like
it's so bad it's good but then uh you
know just just everyone everyone can
realize that when when the really awful
uh Super Bowl commercials come out we
can just make videos about them and talk
about why they're bad that's true and
then uh it's content
yeah business is booming I'm half
kidding by the way I can't wait for
history books to talk about the Super
Bowl commercial that saved America like
what whatever company donates a lot of
money to either a getting the history
books made or be funding the political
career of a politician who decides they
need to use that curriculum is just
going to be blown up like this Super
Bowl ad was revolutionary fix the
country it solved the Civil Rights
struggle whatever one tweet can say all
right BD says need to get VIVA Fry on to
talk about the legal side the government
can and can't do I would love to have
Viva back on especially with this
experience on the ground with the
truckers once they let those
restrictions I bet we can
for oh once they end once they end
ing well once viva's you know wrapping
up his coverage whatever that might be
maybe he'll stay afterwards maybe he'll
he'll leave early I don't know but Viva
we'd love to have you on the show big
fans
you guys can support Viva Frye
f-r-e-i on YouTube he's been streaming
on the ground welcome to Costco
all right Stephen hung says the Convoy
spread all over the world when we win
people of the future will recognize gas
cans and the Canadian goose as symbols
of Freedom not the bald eagle how does
that make you Americans feel Hong Kong I
dig it I don't know the Canada goose is
awesome I'm all for it I got your back
bro and we got we got those those silly
geese here it's the Canada Goose right
not the Canadian goose I think called
Canadian goose you want to Google it oh
yeah
because like Gray Goose yeah yeah that's
a bit different
I was at when I lived in La there are
these giant white geese that hang out at
this one park by the water and they're
massive yeah Canada Goose Canada Goose
and they run up too and they they attack
you and try and steal from you like
they're they're not scared you at all no
they're on the golf course they'd be
scared of me I'd teach them a lesson you
know what I mean tall
the last of my kind says don't fight an
alligator underwater my man Ian rolls a
20 when he said this dude that was in
reference to if someone if you're gonna
argue with someone don't play their game
on in their way well it's true it will
be seed so much to the left by giving
them the linguistic territory right we
use all of their terms and we debate
them it's crazy or the right yep just do
it's attack yeah yeah yeah well it's
because the the you know what it is
The Establishment left is a big click of
trendy morons on the playground who for
no reason like yo-yos but because the TV
told him to and the Republicans are like
the suit wearing statue kids who are
like well
I could yo-yo too but yoyos are dumb
anyway why won't you listen to me I'm
trying to argue with you not every
single person but eventually people
start breaking away and they're like I
don't care for yo-yos man let's go hang
out somewhere else or like the crowd of
Yo-Yo People are just getting really
mean and nasty I just you know I can't
understand is the desire to be a part of
an of a of a mean girl squad you know I
mean that somewhat figuratively like to
throw it back to like The Young Turks
they're just mean people
you know like weary for sure yeah well
me no interesting word like the math the
mean is the average and I think okay
okay stop to stop there they are uh
disrespectful they are angry they are
generally mean people instead of saying
like I I hereby you know I humbly
disagree with with you good sir they
like mock appearances they call people
dumb and stupid they you know Anna's
have hardly been like I'm better than
you like from the guy from globo gym in
Dodge yeah I just don't understand why
anybody would be a fan of like those
people I was watching Hassan uh uh uh
the other like uh this morning when I
was watching his take on Joe Rogan and
he was like Joe's not he's like Joe like
Joe Biden is way more racist than Joe
Rogan I'm like I can understand watching
Hassan at least in that capacity because
like he was like calm about his approach
it's probably why he got so much bigger
than The Young Turks Young Turks are
trying not being so mean to people
because it's kind of off-putting let me
quick review of my theory about the
meaning of life when you talk about the
word mean in math mean as an average how
when they say what is the meaning of
life I believe the meaning is the
process of bringing life back to the
middle and it's constant when things are
bad they get good when things are good
they get bad and that's the meaning
I'm not quite sure that moderation I
understand it's a con it's a present
tense verb just a semantic if I'm mean
to somebody I'm bringing things back to
the middle yeah
sometimes you notice if you're really
nice to mean people they get more Angry
yeah yeah that's the meaning that's the
meaning
I guess so you're bringing there it's
it's like you know it's it's forcing it
apart actually your niceness comes in so
it's an equal and opposite reaction
all right Richard Cranium says Nick
loved you and Justified the chemistry
between you and Timothy Oliphant made
that series great any chance he'll be
present in the upcoming revisitation of
the series
not much of a chance no I mean the
series that they're doing now is set
eight years later I was one year away
from retirement in the show if I if I
show up in this one I'll probably be a
Walmart greeter or something
all right let's grab some more Super
chats Arctic Shadow says the daily wire
is releasing a new movie tonight what a
great night to have on Nick Cersei can
you ask him what he thinks about the
daily wire standing up to Hollywood's
toxic culture
oh well you know I think that what the
daily wire is doing is what we have to
do which is basically build a new
Hollywood we have to we have to build
our own apparatus we have to make our
own movies we have to build platforms to
deliver them and I think you know daily
wire is really uh really kind of setting
the the tone for all that and they made
a really smart decision putting me in
their next movie
Terror on the Prairie coming out June
the 10th with Gina what is that about
it's uh it's well it's Terror on the
Prairie it's about a a family in the um
1880s and I play a
a civil war Captain who's unrepentant
and has a
has a little Revenge that he has to
execute on on a number of people Union
or confederate confederate ah so he's
met at the North and he's no it's more
than that I mean he was it's sort of
like I don't want to give away the whole
point of it you know but he uh you know
he there's a a number of people who were
traitors to him that got his daughter
killed so set the 1880s so you're using
a single action revolvers on set I'd
imagine yeah yeah
Winchester's yeah yeah and it was that
was that where Hannah was the armorer or
no no she was on but it was the other
ones it was Nicholas Cage but it's
similar I mean that one was kind of set
in the same same time period you know
yes so I you know I I was I was trying
to figure out all the guns and stuff
when I was reading about Alec Baldwin
like what gun would it have been would
ammo you know what size and all that
looking at the the era of the movie so
like right when the story broke I
researched the premise of the film the
time period to figure out what kind of
gun he'd be using on set right and then
you quickly learn it was a single action
revolver that can't be fired unless you
pull the trigger right you got to pull
the hammer back first then pull the
trigger yeah so that's that sounds
intentional but hey that's just me yeah
all right let's see we got here
Bobby Moody says give send goes as
Canada has zero jurisdiction over them
that's right
but we'll see how that plays out John S
says The Young Turks have always been
evil even way back when they spoke out
against the Iraq War they only spoke out
because they were paid to hate bush
I mean I don't know about all that and
watch them all that long ago if there's
one thing that chank knows how to do
it's hate he really hated George Bush I
watched I know it's just it's so weird
oh check you're cool man I like you jinx
uh you look I can give him respect for
for his hard work you know and I I mean
that legitimately but I don't understand
why they're so mean maybe that's why
their views you know are lower than they
were in the past like they've got
they've got six top five times the subs
that we do and they get less views per
video and maybe it's because they're
just mean people they're miserable yeah
nobody leftists are basically miserable
at the core I think beyond that too the
fact is everyone knows that if they want
to hear a left-wing perspective on
current issues they just turn their
television on and I understand that tyt
is an establishment left in the exact
same way but that's a much smaller Niche
audience it's true you can get their
stuff all over the place every network
has it yeah Jay mcmiddle he says for Ian
the Turks wouldn't spit on your gums if
your teeth were on fire that's okay
you're a good dude man but bad people
exist propping them up legitimizes them
well I mean I wouldn't expect them to do
anything for me they don't they don't
owe me anything even if your teeth are
on fire bro they don't know me they
don't know me anything
gergy says I don't care what Anna says
to him I think you are one hot hunk of a
man that's right thank you gergy that's
right did they say that to you that's
right I said you're really correct sir
yeah no I don't care if they're mad that
I we recited these studies it's true
conservatives tend to be more attractive
than liberals it's it's literally or is
it that attractive people tend to be
more conservative exactly that was the
point I was making I'm living proof
right absolutely if if you grow up uh
and you're attractive you're going to be
more individualist because you'll get by
easier and think anybody can do this
and if you're ugly you're gonna need to
band together because you have less
power less privilege it was so weird
because I was making like a lefty
argument about privilege and they got
mad at me for it it just goes to show
that it's not about principle or issue I
call it bugs bunnying I do this on
Facebook every so often I get people who
are tribal leftists to argue against
their own positions because I adopt the
position they're supposedly for
so you know I can make comments that are
seemingly pro-choice and then all of a
sudden have these tribal leftists on
Facebook making comments that are
strangely pro-life
like not completely but weirdly in favor
of government control of Health Care
restricting at Women's access it's
called you know you know Bugs Bunny had
the duck season rabbit season thing
right and then he's like it's rabbit
season flips it on Daffy that's why I
call it bugs bunnying so it's like I do
a segment that argues the left position
and then The Young Turks come out make a
video insulting me and mocking the idea
that actually benefits the left's
perspective on privilege I didn't do
that on purpose but it's just a funny
circumstance well and speaking of
pro-choice on the after show big
discussion about Gosnell on the
documentary yeah we're going to be you
guys seriously if you don't know the
story of Gosnell you want to check out
this members only second we're going to
do it's so gruesome that I don't think
we can actually talk about it live on
YouTube and it's not about like an overt
you know getting censored thing it's
it's an overtly unfamily friendly thing
that's going to make a lot of people on
gruesome gruesome but we'll talk about
it watch the segment yeah please yeah
we'll read some more please it's crazy
it's crazy and you you directed or I
directed it yeah and played gosnell's
attorney oh wow
yikes
all right let's see
Gabriel McLeod says on a podcast with
Jordan Peterson and Sam Harris it was
said that quote no amount of evidence
could ever be offered to change the
minds of people who do not value
evidence people will remain willfully
ignorant because it is safe
and that's why it's just don't argue
with these people what's the point we
need to build infrastructure
uh gab is talking about I don't know
maybe not gab but I think they're
talking about doing a payment processor
or something like that yes that was gab
that was a gap Dan bongino was
mentioning they have you know more
right-leaning
um payment processors the right just
needs to build their own infrastructure
so they can't keep they can't be cut out
of the economy and you know what it'll
create a parallel economy but so be it
and their own Entertainment System
yeah absolutely agreed I want to figure
out a way for people to share content on
the internet for free and then it it to
track the content back to the Creator so
that like I can let you sell my movie
without having to interact with you
you'll get a cut and then the majority
goes to me because I'm the Creator but
just for it to be able to be followed
and then I think I'll cut back on piracy
yeah all right Wes says Mr Cersei head
of state you played a very stereotypical
Republican funny movie Chris Rock is
great your bit was funny however how do
you look back on that 2003 film in
today's political climate
I was actually playing Al Gore Chris
Rock even told me he said you're doing
Al Gore aren't you
because it was very stiff and you know
it just sort of you know the the
characterization but I mean you know
that that movie was it's one of those uh
movies that doesn't say which party
anybody's in you know it they never
identified it as democrat or republican
but you know you have the uh the
progressive sort of black candidate
Chris Rock and I'm the uh I'm the vice
president who thinks it's my turn to be
president so that's Al Gore I didn't I
didn't see it that I was playing a
republican I was playing Al Gore
oh interesting all right Taylor cook
says a law is just what some group of
people with just enough power agree to
this is why morality is so important
legal doesn't mean right illegal doesn't
mean wrong and a good example of this is
if you think the law is what matters a
big mistake the Republicans made just
going for judges there are many laws in
the books that we don't enforce have you
ever seen these stories about like wacky
old laws there's like a what I like to
reference where it's you can't put a pie
on your windowsill on Sundays or
something like that and it was because
back in the day when you lived in these
small towns it would attract bears or
something now it's meaningless so you
put a pie in your windowsill nobody
cares but it's overtly illegal which
don't care anymore so the law is is it
means a lot less than cultural
enforcement
if tomorrow every person in America woke
up and said you know it should be
illegal to do jumping jacks then the
cops would be like hey look everybody
wants us to arrest you for doing this
you know it just happened
Stephen says I love the sound of honking
in the morning it smells like Victory
yes
Greta Thanos all right says people need
to wake up and realize the tactics being
deployed are in direct Defiance of the
Constitution with the intent to destroy
the Constitution this entire scenario
ends with the extermination of anyone of
Western European descent I don't know
about that that part at the end I think
it's more about ideologies because if
you look at the um uh Latino migrants in
this country they're starting to become
overwhelmingly pro-freedom and they're
siding with Republicans on a lot of
these issues so a lot of people you know
I I I can't stand the um
people who see who think race is the is
the key component of everything that's
going on because it's not it's ideology
right and it is completely ideology and
when they talk about diversity they only
are talking about race they're certainly
not talking about diversity of opinion
right that's why they said black panther
was a diverse movie even though the
majority of actors in it were black yeah
it's not it's just whoa that's right I
forgot about that yeah yeah
all right Tony bones says Nick Cersei
AKA US Marshal art Mullen and I just
started re-watching Justified still as
great as I remember
right on great show yeah yeah
all right let's see what else we got
here
let's see I don't know what that one
means so we'll just keep going
Brian ackner says if it was an
Insurrection who stopped it also Lydia
when can you get Patrick and Adriana
from Red pilled America on oh they are
creating some great content interesting
I'll look them up they're good friends
of mine oh cool they did an episode on
me not long ago very cool
all right
Ben Hixson says Tim to an abused spouse
you need to get away from them Ian to an
abused spouse they still love they could
change Ian is the problem allowing bad
faith actors to get away with everything
for peace I actually lived in an
apartment building about six years ago
and I could hear the man beating the
woman through the wall he would come
home from work and she'd be like and
then he'd be like meh and then I'd hear
me he'd go meh and then he'd go erratic
like she taunted him and then he'd start
slamming walls and her screaming so I
called the cops bro do what's right
all right here's a very important one
bomb Globe says Ian babe baby hun
sweetie
that's it that's what I'm talking about
Jason Adams says Nick Cersei is amazing
art Mullen rules Ian he sounds like a
plan a a plant from the feds that's what
I'm trying to portray don't you get it
we need diversity he's a method actor
yeah sure Daniel Brent said Ian's
rolling a 20 tonight in the form of 20
different ones
who said that Daniel Daniel Bryan what's
up dude nice one so uh in dungeons of
dragons you roll for things to happen
and when you roll 20 it's the highest
you can get so it's like critical
success and when you roll a one it's
abysmal failure so that's what it means
when he enrolls I'm extreme okay it
means he's not doing he's making bad
points leave it to me but there are some
people who who who uh who like Ian you
know yeah they're evil
I do well on shows like this because
when I swing and Miss Tim's really good
or you guys like being like yeah I'll
take this one guy
Jason M says
I don't know I can't I don't know if I
can make out what you're trying to say
in the beginning he says are you sure
you know Ian 100 he talks like he's a
plant from the feds seriously pay
attention to his words
yes we know Ian I don't think he is a
plan I don't think Ian does enough like
if he was a fed the feds would be like
come on do something I had a vision last
night of going to congress with Thomas
Massey and telling everyone about
friendship and how important it is and
bringing them all together and having a
picnic okay that needs to be a cartoon
let's all go let's get Congress to win a
picnic together the power of friendship
that's like my little I looked over at
Nancy Pelosi she was like he's right
like after all said and done it is about
like hanging out with your friends well
I mean to be fair Nancy Pelosi and Mitch
McConnell realizing their friends and
then just like you know going on top of
a building and having watching a hunger
game style fight of poor people while
they drink expensive wine he has the
kind of friendship they'd have maybe
they are friends and it's theater yeah
yeah I bet they are
says Ian I love you brother man you are
rolling ones tonight Tammy should look
into getting John Shaffer on he's an
amazing guitar player in the band Iced
Earth and he was at the capitol for
January 6. was he in the capital or was
he at the rally it's an interesting
question
A.A dub says last night was the first
time in my 41 years that I donated to a
political campaign I sent fifty dollars
to both 25 years in the kitchen 15 years
as a chef I would like a chance to help
with freedomastan or as a private Chef
if if you're interested awesome jacket
Nick
does she sell stuff sell clothes no she
just said she started quilting a few
years ago and then she's built up to
this so it's just awesome it's
incredible it's cool we uh we are
planning on hiring a chef yeah yeah but
um I don't know to what degree we can
get a good Chef you know I had a chef
hit me up just now during the show and
he wants to come on talk about it you
know yeah so this guy so the idea is
with the new facility and as we're
expanding it will actually be cheaper
for us to have someone buy the food and
cook it as opposed to constantly
ordering out super expensive and
unhealthy yeah and for the crew for a
variety of reasons we often do order so
we can have events here either for
meetings or because we're having a
get-together for you know we filmed the
green room and so we need supplies so we
were thinking I was thinking about I'm
like we could we could just hire someone
they could it'll be so much cheaper to
just pick up a bunch of steaks from the
store and then just make some really
healthy stuff everyone would be eating
better
we would be saving us money and you'd be
hiring getting someone a job and we'd be
creating jobs we would be job creators
that's right
that's right just make sure they're not
infiltrators yeah yeah
Ian has to eat it first I sure will
Diane Isis says Ian Ian's role streaks
is taking a hit this match come back
we'll come out of nowhere come back
we'll come out of nowhere he will it
will there will be if anyone thinks he's
rolling ones there will be a comeback
he's Gonna Roll twice I learned at
school actually when I was little I used
to get all A's and then I started
getting a minuses and B's and they're
like what's wrong and I was like I don't
like doing homework they're like well
and I realized they expected me to get
A's because I had gotten A's before so I
was like well if I if I try a little
less then they won't expect too much
from me yeah so that's kind of how I
live I B plus and then when I crack it
out of the park they're like whoa yeah
yeah I had kind of an epiphany when I
was a kid and I was just like grades
don't matter huh what's the point I said
that to a teacher all you got to do is
pass and D passes if you want to go to
the next grade just do the bear please
get degrees
they used to say
what do you get by getting straight A's
and I was just like my whole life I got
straight A's and for what I like it and
so I was just like me my buddy's dad
gave him like 20 bucks an a I thought
that well I guess so it depends on if
you want to go off to a prestigious
University you've got to have a really
high GPA but yeah I didn't do that yeah
I didn't do it either Marshall uh
Marshall says can Nick yell Parker
yell but is that from something Parker
yeah that was a show called seven days
1998 to 2001. yeah old school I've been
around a long time I'm tired what year
did you start
um well I moved to New York in 1982
after college to be an actor would you
go to college
University of North Carolina was it for
acting
English major but I did a lot of plays
was there act like acting how do you get
into acting in New York is it show up
and knock on someone's door yeah
auditioned for plays I mean back then
the way you the path for an actor back
then was you get a play you and you get
somebody to come see you yeah you know
because there wasn't YouTube there
wasn't anything you know and so he just
tried to get get somebody to come see
you in a play and you like send Flyers
to agencies and be like I'm going to be
performing here yeah send out little
postcards with your picture on it hi
this week I did this and then I had a
few beers and or whatever you're just
trying to put your face in it was so
interesting to be in Hollywood during
the transition to internet video because
people kept doing that they kept sending
postcards and I was like dude it's 2007.
right if people were watching YouTube
yeah but it took that took them so long
to transition I still have musicians
that I'll meet and they'll be a lie I'll
be like you have some music like I have
CDs not even kidding what yeah and I'm
like what I don't have a CD player for
real I got some cassettes yeah I can't
even put it in my PlayStation doesn't
even play CDs eight tracks only well you
know the DVDs are for the old people oh
but people can get it online too we'll
talk about that at the end okay yeah
Justin says can you adopt a Canadian I
hate it here we can't it's actually
really hard to hire Canadians it's crazy
move down
you can do it you got to move here you
know
correct well if he's vaccinated you know
yeah
yeah all right let's grab another Super
Chat just scrolling through and see we
got going on
I can't read this name because it's in
what looks like simplified Cantonese but
they said en is incomprehensible LMAO
absolutely insane I love it
here's the thing
there have been I think three
conversations we've had where you
started you started arguing not based on
what we're talking about but on a
different definition of the word I'm
glad you noticed and well people aren't
fans I don't know well we could get into
that later like the easiest example is
the one is when I said they're so mean
you said mean means average
sometimes if people are being really
nice all the time you see people get
angry and then if some people are really
angry all the time you see people trying
to be nice but that's mean but the
purpose is why are you why are you
trying to change you weren't
meaningfully engaging with the
conversation you might be right about
that yeah I think that's what they're
saying so it's also interesting what
they say it sounds like I'm saying
nonsense it's like if some two people
are talking Spanish and you don't
understand it it's gonna sound like
they're talking in nonsense LOL what are
they even talking about they're they're
stupid because they're not making any
sense but just because you don't
understand them your real says Ian check
your last Twitter post I sent you a link
to your orbit commercial oh cool oh
Ian's got a Super Bowl commercial yeah I
end up running on the Super Bowl it was
weird it was uh early on in my careers
but third commercial I did I did a Dr
Pepper commercial uh people don't people
never read Because we've had people be
like who's this Ian guy like we know
Freedom Tunes like yo
yeah I definitely had a chance to go
into that career path to Hollywood
career but YouTube was so enticing just
being able to speak my mind the freedom
that comes with that is immeasurable
monetarily
Missy says Tim are you coming around to
my line of thinking that Vice news
provoking supremacists in
Charlottesville was theater nope
yeah I think white I think Vice went
down there to film to get clicks that's
what Vice news does yeah advice used to
be good it really did that's why I
wanted to work there and when we went on
the ground and we covered these stories
there was no one telling us what we had
to do it was just we just covered the
stories it was a lot of fun I really
liked Hannibal burris's um he would like
go and do different drugs in different
countries where they would animal Burris
is that his list no not Burris that's a
comedian shout out Hannibal cat what's
Hannibal's name last name I don't think
his name is Hannibal
you're right what were you talking about
the guy who he's a vice documentary he's
the son of that filmmaker guy
oh man Vice had this great guy yeah yeah
look Google Vice drug guy people are
people are gonna they'll chat his name
Hamilton Hamilton Morris I think is his
last name well Hamilton
yes all right here's what we're gonna do
I want to talk to you uh Nick about your
your film Gosnell that story and a lot
more around Hollywood but this is such a
gruesome story that it's going to be on
the member segment so go to timcast.com
become a member sign up we'll have this
up for you around 11 or so p.m watch it
watch all of the other content we have
in our library we had Thomas Massey and
Marjorie Taylor green on last night that
was a really interesting conversation
and we are funded by your memberships it
helps run this business so we're
eternally grateful you can follow me at
timcast on Instagram or wherever you can
follow the show at timcastirl uh Nick
did you want to shout anything out
I'm sorry I took my head off you want to
shout anything out oh no just go to
Capital punishmentthemovie.com and check
out the documentary do you have a social
media Twitter or anything like that yeah
yes Nick Cersei at Twitter I don't
recommend it I have my my button
hovering over the follow are you sure
it's an it's a knife fight my Twitter
feed following you anyway I'm very mean
yeah I'm very mean guy I might unfollow
you but it's not personal all right it's
all about medicine my mother keeps
telling me you need to shut that thing
down that is you need to get off that
Twitter do you think Twitter has brought
out the best in anyone no ever yeah it's
so horrible a good day on Twitter is
like you were mean to someone else but
people thought it was funny and then a
bad day on Twitter is everyone's being
mean to you it's just a horrible
platform what the website is hold on
hold on it's true I ignore responses so
people are mean to me and I don't care
yeah and I I'm not mean to other people
no I'm I'm I'll quote them maybe but I
really love it you know it's like you
know when I post nonsense on Twitter and
people eat it up well yeah no you can
also just post jokes too but I think the
vast majority of it is just people
trying to dunk on each other I love I
love it I hate it for a long time I
think it's destroying civilization but I
love I love how serious journalists take
it yeah oh and I can post the stupidest
thing and they write a story like I I
wrote impeach the queen yes and I got a
whole article written up about me saying
Tim pool calls for impeaching Queen
Elizabeth it's it's amazing I love it
yeah that's hysterical no I look at it
like improv class it's like you know I'm
just sort of trading barbs with people
you know workshopping jokes here yeah
well um my name is Seamus Coughlin I'm a
cartoonist I have a YouTube channel
called Freedom Tunes we release a new
cartoon every Thursday we released one
today called fed talks about the
involvement of feds and trying to
infiltrate right-wing movements and
attract people I think you guys are
going to enjoy it it's doing pretty well
and thank you so much for stopping by
and watching the show and I hope you
check out my YouTube channel I'm Ian
Crossland great to see you guys Nick
thank you so much for coming in and this
is the topic on the documentaries
capital punishment can I keep this one
yeah yeah absolutely I'm really
interested in this and I really I think
these people that are in prison these
people in solitary confines this is like
the most maybe under-talked about maybe
next to the war in Yemen the genocide in
Yemen right now this is like very it's
unbelievably awful and you know there's
a guy in there testifies about how he's
been how he was treated when he was in
there by the prison guards it is really
really sick and it's it shouldn't be
happening yeah capital punishment you
guys check it out
and thank you guys very much for tuning
in I have been remiss in my freedom
Tunes watching I need to catch up on
this one
I'm so sorry Sheamus all right I get it
hey we all get busy I know anyway you
guys can follow me on Twitter and
minds.com at Sour Patch Lids thanks for
hanging out everybody go to timcast.com
become a member and we will see you all
there bye guys